Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, machst du jetzt auch mit Politik am Küchen Tisch?
Nee, da müsste ich nur Ruhe essen.
Das stimmt. Der Küchentisch ist doch zum Essen da. Wer kommt auch so ihre Ideen, dort jetzt Politik machen zu wollen? Johannes Müller-Salo. Ich kannte ihn nicht. Kennst du ihn?
Nein, er ist 1988 geboren, wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter am Institut für Philosophie der Leibniz-Universität Hannover. Und er hat bei Reclam jetzt dieses Buch veröffentlicht. Offene Rechnungen, der kalte Konflikt der Generationen. Und ich habe dieses Buch gesehen in der Ankündigung und dachte, nimmt da jemand vielleicht schon Stefans Buch vorweg, müssen wir da mal reinschauen oder musst du noch mal was revidieren? Ich glaube, diese Gefahr besteht nicht. Das kann man dann später noch mal gerne abgleichen. Aber ich würde jetzt mal, ohne auch nur eine Zeile deines bald erscheinenden Buches gelesen zu haben, behaupten, deines wird anders sein. So ist auch zu hoffen. Und ich bin sehr ratlos, was dieses Buch anbelangt. Denn was hier zunächst einmal angekündigt wird, ist ja zu sagen, es gibt einen Konflikt zwischen den Generationen. Da sind noch Rechnungen offen, wie der Titel sagt. Und jetzt würde ja jeder schnell nachdenken können, welche offenen Rechnungen könnte das sein. Und dann fällt uns relativ viel ein. Da ist selbstverständlich das Thema Klimawandel. Da wäre aber auch das Thema Wohnen, Rente, Vermögen. Wir könnten über Verkehr sprechen, über verschiedene Dinge, Erziehung, Kinderbetreuung, all diese ganzen Dinge. Also alles, was mit Demografie zusammenhängt, mit diesen Fragen zusammenhängt, haben die Boomer schön abgeschöpft. Und für uns bleibt jetzt nicht mehr allzu viel da. Ist das nur eine Frage, die man jetzt auf Generationen zuschieben kann? Oder wo liegt auch das politische Versagen, das sich ja bis heute durchzieht, auch wenn wir ja nicht nur noch Boomer an der Regierung haben. Viele Fragen, die sich da anschließen. Und auch eine philosophische oder mehrere philosophische Fragen. Deswegen habe ich das Buch auch erst mal interessant gefunden. Denn wir könnten ja zum Beispiel fragen, warum eigentlich muss die jetzige Generation für die nächste Generation irgendetwas vorbereiten oder tun? Also das ist ja erst mal eine philosophische Frage. Man könnte ja auch sagen, ja, hier und jetzt kann ja auch eine Ethik sein. Wie könnte man philosophisch dagegen argumentieren? Wer so etwas erwartet von diesem Buch, der findet da leider keine Antworten. Und auch sonst habe ich, um das gleich mal polemisch zuzuspitzen, eher den Eindruck, das ist so ein Bewerbungsschreiben für schöne Podien mit der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung.
Ja, du bist jetzt schon mit dem Urteil so all-in. Und es ist alles richtig, ich würde das alles unterschreiben. Weil es sich ja wirklich die Frage stellt, so Generationen. Es ist mir ja auch untergekommen als Thema. Das Buch heißt Die Alten Republik, Arbeitszettel Rentenrepublik. Da geht es also Rente um alt, aber nicht nur alt, sondern schon die Republik, also uns alle irgendwie. Wie fasst man so ein Panorama-Thema? Also ein Thema, wo man entweder all in oder gar nicht hat. Man hat so das Gefühl, wie kriegt man es eigentlich zu fassen? Denn du hast ja eben so ein paar Themen aufgezählt. Man könnte ja auch ein Buch nur über Rente, nur über Bildung, nur über Wohnkosten, nur über Vermögen und so, nur über Erbe und so weiter schreiben. Aber hier geht es ja darum, mal zu sagen, ne, das Buch rechtfertigt sich aus diesem Panoramablick. So, und das ist super schwer. Und dann gibt es aber eine große Falle, in die man tappen kann, in der man nämlich sagt, ja, ich will über die Gesellschaft schreiben, weil, ne, er macht Philosophie, ich hab Soziologie gemacht. Das ist also irgendwie so mein Thema. Und dann ist die Tür, durch die man gehen will, Generation. Und dann ist man ganz schnell beim Konflikt, alt gegen jung, der Generationenkonflikt. Und ich hab's jetzt bei mir im Buch nicht explizit. Ich hatte jetzt, als ich es hier gelesen habe, wieder gedacht, okay, vielleicht hätten wir es nochmal explizieren sollen. Es geht gar nicht um Generation, sondern es geht um Demografie. Und das unterscheidet sich ein bisschen von Generation. Das ist ein bisschen wie, man redet über Emanzipation, ah, über die Frau. Ne, das muss nicht nur über die Frau gehen, sondern Emanzipation ist ein übergeordnetes, allgemeines Problem, das man überall mal so anwenden kann. Man hat Neulinge in einer Organisation, die man behandeln kann. Ja, man hat überall Treffen so Fragen der Emanzipation, des Hineinwachsens, des Aufgenommen-Wertens, des Sich-Anbietens, des Angenommen-Wertens und so weiter. Kann man immer wieder thematisieren. Also, man braucht so ein Ebene-Zweiblick, so eine Abstraktion, irgendwo so eine Emergenz, die es rechtfertigt, die Themen, die du genannt hast, alle aufzugreifen, aber dann eben aufgehangen an so einem Oberthema. Und da hat sich Müller-Salo hier für Generation entschieden. Und das auch von Anfang an als Konflikt thematisiert. Und das halte ich für ein Fehler. Das ist einfach nicht gut. Denn dann liest man es nur als Anklageschrift, weil man ordnet sich ja einer der beiden Seiten zu. Er sagt ja auch ganz klar, ja gut, die Generation, man könnte sie so durchgehen. Also die Vorteile des bisherigen demografischen, wie war das genannt? Nicht das Gegenteil von Defizit. Na, das kommt auch schon mit Worten durcheinander. Aber bisher gab es Vorteile, die einzuheimsen waren Dividende. Generation Dividende, die hat nun unklar, ist es die Generation Z oder die Millennials oder die Generation X, denen es noch ganz gut ging. Und bei ihm ist klar, die Babyboomer haben alle profitiert und alle anderen verteilen so die Nachteile unter sich. Und das ist schwierig. Am Anfang, viele Jüngere haben das Gefühl, mit dem Rücken an der Wand zu stehen. Viele stimmt, aber da stellt sich die Frage, wie viele genau? Und das ist eine ganz wichtige Frage bei diesen Generationen-Fragen.
Die man auch beantworten kann. Es gibt ja auch noch mal Umfragen, zum Beispiel, wovor hat die junge Generation Angst? Es gibt auch Umfragen, die jetzt sagen, wer fühlt sich da mit dem Rücken zur Wand oder was. Aber wovor hat die junge Generation Angst? Ich weiß jetzt nicht gerade, welche Alters-Kohorte da befragt wurde. Aber da zeigt sich, auf Platz eins ist jetzt der Krieg. Also man hat Angst davor, dass wir bald nicht mehr in friedlichen Zeiten leben. Davor war es der Klimawandel. Das heißt aber nicht, dass der Krieg den Klimawandel abgelöst hat, das ist das Interessante, sondern die Angst vor dem Klimawandel ist gleich hoch. Es ist nur jetzt auch noch der Krieg dazugekommen. Und solche Zahlen hat man ja, die kann man ja mal anführen, wenn man möchte.
Genau, wir haben auf zwei Ebenen ganz genaue Zahlen. Zum einen, wie ist der Gemütszustand der Jüngeren? Hurelmann, der hat ja auch lange im Bielfeld gelebt, da habe ich auch ein paar Seminare bei ihm mal so mitgemacht. Er kam aus der Pädagogik, hat ja immer die Shell-Studie gemacht, da kam 2015 die letzte. Jetzt hat er gerade wieder so eine Jugendstudie, die läuft aber nicht unter Shell. Wahrscheinlich ist einfach nur der Hausgeber und Finanzier ausgetauscht, wie auch immer. Da kann man sich jetzt auch die ersten, wo Corona mal so richtig drin ist, als Thema anschauen. Und dann gibt es natürlich ganz allgemein die Frage, wie viele sind es denn? Also nicht nur, wie viele haben gerade Probleme, sondern wie viele Jungen sind es denn? Und da es relativ viel weniger sind, als es Alte gibt, ergibt sich allein daraus eine demografische Schieflage, die man mal thematisieren müsste. Da muss man aber beide Zahlen mal nennen. Und das passiert hier in dem Buch nicht. Also wir haben weder eine Aufklärung, Generationenkonflikte, die Alten haben es von den Jungen genommen oder so, aber wem haben sie es denn weggenommen? Also man könnte ja auch sagen, ja klar haben die Alten irgendwie ein Recht darauf, auf mehr zuzugreifen. Es gibt ja viel weniger Jüngere, die Ansprüche haben. Also man muss ja weniger verteilen und so. Und solche Spielereien sind ja gar nicht möglich, denn wir werden gar nicht über Zahlen aufgeklärt, sondern wir erfahren nur, ok, es gibt eine Sorge ums Klima, deswegen will keiner mehr Kinder haben. Diese Diskussion ist super kompliziert, die müsste man sich auch nochmal genau anschauen. Ich habe das auch so ein bisschen versucht, diesen Kinderwunsch. Es gibt ja dieses Phänomen Regretting Motherhood und dann ist wirklich die Frage, traut man sich jetzt keine Kinder zu oder will man den Kindern das künftige Klima nicht zutrauen und so weiter. Also hat man wirklich keinen Kinderwunsch mehr oder leidet man selber darunter, dass man seinen Kinderwunsch nicht mehr umsetzen möchte, weil man Schlimmeres befürchtet, als man selber an emotionalen Profit oder so als Kinder jetzt ziehen würde. Also alles sowieso super heikel, wird hier einfach um Shift, Sorge um die Rente. Genau, da ist es super wichtig, mal über die Zahlen zu reden, denn wissen wir uns in Deutschland wirklich um die Möglichkeit. Also brauchen wir... Wir sind ja reich geworden, bevor wir alt wurden. Es gibt ja Länder, die wir mit Namen zum Beispiel, die wurden alt und sind aber gar nicht vorher reich geworden. Die haben wirklich auch nichts zu verteilen. Hier in Deutschland haben wir wenigstens noch was zu verteilen. Wir könnten also eine Rentendiskussion führen, wenn wir wollten.
Und du hast jetzt gerade das schon angesprochen mit der Rente. Wir sind in einem reichen Land. Also könnte man ja auch andere Gelder zur Verfügung stellen. Also niemand müsste an Altersarmut leiden. Und auch in zehn Jahren nicht. Das ist einmal eine Frage der Umverteilung, aber dann natürlich auch eine Frage, wie fasst man so etwas wie Staatsschulden oder so auf? Und das finde ich, ist wirklich das ebenso große Manko bei diesem Buch, dass ein einfach vollkommen falsches Schuldenverständnis da ist. Und ich erwarte, wenn heute jemand, und gerade wenn er noch so jung ist, ein Buch schreibt über Generationen, über Schulden, dass dann auch mal die moderne Ökonomik mit hinzugenommen wird. Und dass man nicht, wenn man von Schulden spricht, einen Brief zitiert, der von, an wen war das nochmal? Dieser Brief geht an Jefferson. Genau Madison schreibt einen Brief an Jefferson. Also einen 200 Jahre alten Brief, wie mit Schulden umgegangen werden und wie das generationengerecht ist. Also da muss ich sagen, das ist ein schönes Zitat. Das kann man sich vielleicht noch mal irgendwo hinhängen, aber das hat einfach damit nichts zu tun. Das muss man jetzt wirklich mal so begreifen, wenn jetzt jemand einen Herzinfarkt hat, dann kann man auch nicht sagen, ja, vielleicht ein Adalaz wird helfen oder so. Sondern da muss man sagen, gut, wir haben eine moderne Medizin und da muss jetzt was getan werden, damit der Mensch überlebt. Und genauso haben wir es hier bei den Schulden auch mit etwas zu tun, wo man nicht sagen kann, ich habe da mal ein schönes altes Zitat gefunden, ist zwar 230 Jahre alt, aber was soll es, wir bringen es jetzt einfach mal. Und dadurch wird dann auch so vieles falsch. Das heißt dann, die Jüngeren können das Geld mehr als gut gebrauchen. Aber dann wird da gleich gesprochen, ja, zur Tilgung der Staatsschulden und zur Stabilisierung der Rentenkassen. Und dann wird immer wieder so getan, als seien es die Älteren, die Schulden wollen. Also es heißt dann hier, für die Älteren könnte die Lage kaum besser sein. Erst überziehen sie jahrzehntelang ihr Emissionsbudget zu Lasten der Jüngeren, dann reden sie erfolgreich sehr viel über die Zukunft und sehr wenig über die Vergangenheit. So erreichen sie am Ende, dass der Klimaschutz zu großen Teilen über Schulden finanziert wird, für die ebenfalls vor allem die Jüngeren aufkommen werden. Also ein Bild wird hier gezeichnet, als sei es die Boomer-Generation, die jetzt wie Wildschulden für den Klimaschutz machen will. Wo sehe ich das? Wo gibt es diese Boomer? Ich würde sie gerne einmal kennenlernen.
Genau, also das ist ganz verquär.
Die jungen Leute sagen doch gerade, da würde ich ja dann auch noch mal unsere Hupfdohlen in Schutz nehmen, die sagen ja, was nutzt mir eine solide Finanzpolitik, wenn ich auf dem Planeten nicht mehr ordentlich leben kann.
Ja, also hier ist einfach, was die politische Debatte angeht, ein kategorialer Fehler im Text. Denn es ist nicht die Friedrich-März-Generation, die uns gerade in Schulden reinquatscht, sondern genau das Gegenteil, die wollen uns ausreden. Und dann nützt auch das Argument gar nichts. Schuldenpolitik kann man ja machen, aber dann sollte man die Generationfragen immer einpreisen, sodass die junge Generation auch was davon hat. Das schwebt völlig im luftleeren Raum, aufgehangen an diesem Jefferson-Zitat. Da würde ich wieder sagen, man muss es nicht ganz aus dem Diskurs raushalten, man kann es durchaus aufgreifen. Wenn einem gute Reime dazu einfallen, dann kriegt man auch einen 3-Stunden-Musical dazu hin. Das hat uns auch historisch eingefangen und dargestellt, wie es damals war. Aber eben in diesem Kontext, es ist wirklich weit, weit, weit weg. Sowohl historisch, als auch von der politischen Debatte, die wir gerade führen. In der Ansicht, ja, dieser Text schwebt so ein bisschen vor sich hin. Und er wird ja auch entschuldigt, indem Müller-Salo behauptet, er philosophiert in dem Buch Renour und sagt es dann, also macht er am Anfang auf und ganz am Ende schließt er die Klammer, um es nicht politisieren zu müssen, denn das sollen ja Politiker tun. Ich bin auch großer Fan davon. Ich habe auch im Finale in meinem Buch geschrieben, wo ich einfach sage, naja, man kann jetzt ewig über das Problem reden und Lösungsvorschläge machen, aber am Ende muss jetzt die Politik mal mit Punkten kommen, die auch umsetzbar sind, und zwar in der parlamentarischen Debatte, also nicht nur in der groben politischen, sondern in der parlamentarischen Debatte, wie es dort möglich ist. Und auch das dauert immer Anlauf. Da muss man erst mal zweimal so richtig auf die Fresse fliegen, mit irgendeiner Argumentation, bis man, das erlebt die FDP gerade, die hat jetzt den Tankrabatt. Vor 10 Jahren oder wann war es ihre Mövenpicksteuer, diese Hotelsteuer. Und irgendwann ist dieser Kreditverbrauch, den sie da immer hat mit, ja, ja, die kümmern sich ums Geld und so weiter. Irgendwann sieht man, nee, wenn selbst Michael Hüther und Ivo Präsident Füß sagen, nee, Tankrabatt ist nur wirklich totaler Müll, dann versteht's irgendwann jeder. Aber, wie gesagt, das braucht halt eine Weile. Jetzt ad hoc irgendwas lösen zu wollen, also das ist ja auch, man schreibt so ein Buch über die ganze Gesellschaft. Und dann wird natürlich erwartet, dass da irgendwie eine Lösung drinsteht. Und klar, dann kann man nur sagen, ja, die Politik sollte es ja einfach mal machen. Aber da ist es eben wichtig, dass man zumindest das Problem mal ordentlich thematisiert. Und es findet hier nichts statt. Denn sobald er abgehandelt hat, dass viele Jüngere mit dem Gefühl rücken an der Wand, Sorge ums Klima, Sorge um die Rente, seit Jahrzehnten, und das ist jetzt ein Zitat, seit Jahrzehnten verschärft sich unausgesprochen und unübersehbar der Konflikt zwischen den Generationen. Es wird Zeit, ihn offen auszutragen. Da würde ich sagen, nein, das ist nicht richtig. Und er hat dann noch das viel ältere Zitat von Sokrates, der auch schon immer meinte, die Jungen können sich nicht benehmen und so. Und man sich auch fragt, muss das echt nochmal in dem Text vorkommen? Der, der es kennt, kennt es halt. Und der, der es nicht kennt, fragt sich, ja, aber was hat das jetzt mit diesem Thema zu tun? Und dann ist er...
Dass ihm ja auch nur zugeschrieben ist.
Das auch, genau, gut, das betont er ja auch nochmal. Das ist nochmal unklar, warum man es verwendet. Und dann kommt er ja mit rasenden Schnritten überfliegt, sozusagen die ganze Debatte, die er führen will, und sagt, wir brauchen das als Querschnitt- und Konfliktsthema. So, wir brauchen also ein belastbares Lagebild, das irgendwie alle politischen Felder abdeckt, so wie wir früher keinen Europaausschuss hatten, sondern Europa einfach in jedem Ausschuss eine Rolle spielte. Wir brauchen einen Internetminister oder in jedem Ministerium das Internet, so wie wir jetzt das Alter da auch reinbringen. Aber wir sehen überhaupt nicht, wo will das denn aufhängen? Ja, das ist mir schleierhaft.
Man kann einfach nur dann da sitzen und sagen, ja, es ist schön, dass wir mal über alles geredet haben. Und gerade immer, wenn er konkret wird, dann wird das auch geradezu falsch. Also ich habe ja das mit den Schulden schon angesprochen. Und das wird ja dann auch, wenn er mal eine Zahl bringt, noch ein bisschen irrer. Also zum Beispiel heißt es dann, dass man hier mit Blick auf die Bundesrepublik und die Schulden ja auch Folgendes feststellen kann. Obwohl die Bundesrepublik Jahrzehnte des wirtschaftlichen Aufschwungs erlebt hat, ist die Verschuldung der öffentlichen Haushalte von Bund, Ländern und Gemeinden kontinuierlich angewachsen. Von 10 Milliarden Euro im Jahr 1950 auf 2,1 Billionen Euro im Jahr 2020. Warum sollte die Erzählung realistisch sein, wenn sie nicht einmal für einen so langen Zeitraum ungetrübten Wohlstandsmehrung aufgeht? Gefragt ist politische Wachsamkeit der Jüngeren. Sie sollten schnell hellhörig werden, wenn Schuldenmacherei ihnen gönnerhaft als Akt der Zukunftsvorsorge angepriesen wird. Ja, wir leben in einem Kapitalismus. Der Kapitalismus lebt davon, dass Kredite gemacht werden, das investiert wird in die Zukunft. So funktioniert Unternehmertum im Kleinen, und so funktioniert Konzernlogik im Großen, und so funktioniert auch ein kapitalistischer Staat. Und dass wir bei einem System, das auf Wachstum ausgerichtet sind, natürlich nicht deflationäre Tendenzen haben dürfen, sondern dass wir natürlich das Geldmehren, also eine Ausweitung der Geldmenge haben und auch eine Ausweitung der Schulden. Das ist ja nun vollkommen logisch, sonst bricht das ganze System sich zusammen. Also wenn wir zu diesen 10 Milliarden Euro von 1950 zurückkommen wollen, dann können wir aber hier wirklich den Laden dicht machen. Und es gibt ja auch keine vergleichbare Entwicklung. Wenn wir jetzt mal irgendwelche Entwicklungsländer rausnehmen, aber kein Industrieland wie Deutschland irgendwo im Westen hat gesagt, wir müssten mal wieder auf den Schuldenstand von 1950 zahlen oder so. Alle Großbritannien, USA, alle haben natürlich immer mehr Staatsschulden gehabt. Und das ist auch gar kein Problem, solange das in einer guten Balance ist und man nicht einfach nur jetzt einen hirnristigen Luxus finanziert. Also da hat ja auch Madison an Jefferson geschrieben Recht, wenn er dann sagt, dass es jetzt nicht darum geht, dass man einfach nur auf Jux und Dollerei lebt. Also es geht jetzt nicht, dass wir Schulden aufnehmen, damit Senioren möglichst viele Kreuzfahrten im Jahr machen können. Das wäre jetzt tatsächlich äußerst dumm. Aber das fordert ja auch niemand ein. Also ich weiß überhaupt gar nicht, wie man so wenig im ökonomischen Diskurs drin sein kann, wenn man zugleich sich anschickt, ein Buch über Generationen zu schreiben. Und ein Kapitel immerhin, nehmen und geben, Rente, Schulden, Wohnen nennt. Und Wohnen, da erfahren wir ja auch nichts, wie es dann geregelt sein soll.
Ja, Wohnen halte ich selbst für das wichtigste und größte Thema, sowohl finanziell, es sind die Wohnkosten, die den Jungen die Möglichkeiten nehmen, für ihr Alter selbst vorzusorgen. Und natürlich wie Wohnen, immer nur Singles oder Familien. Nein, Henning Scherff hat es doch uns allen erklärt, im Grunde. Kleiner Rückzugsraum, große Gemeinschaft. Und das Ziel ist, ich formuliere es so, Urlaub für den Rest des Lebens. Wenn man aus der Arbeitswelt ausschaltet, muss man sich wie im Urlaub fühlen, bis man stirbt. Das ist das Ziel. Und politisch ist das gar nicht so schwer zu machen. Man muss nur neben Geld auch mal ein bisschen über Geselligkeit nachdenken. Und diese grundsätzliche Schieflage, die wir hier drin haben, die wir über Geld-Thematisierung, du hast es jetzt mehrfach angesprochen, Staatsschulden ist ja nur das eine. Es sind ja auch die privaten Vermögen, die so ein bisschen unklar, undeutlich und eben auch unfair nach Wohnkosten und Eigentum verteilt sind.
Kommt nichts. Kein Plädoyer für eine Erbschaftssteuer oder so. Das ist alles nicht zu finden.
Das ist einfach Schweigen. Und stattdessen, und vielleicht ist das dieser philosophische Touch, den er dem Buch geben will. Hier ist eine ganz große Schieflage drin. Denn zum einen sagt er, das Problem ist nicht, dass die Älteren zu viel Positives aus den Verhältnissen gezogen haben, was die Jungen jetzt nicht mehr schaffen, weshalb es zu so einer Ungerechtigkeit kommt. Da haben wir ja im Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil auch die Freiheit in den Entscheidungen der Älteren beschneidet, den Möglichkeitenraum, in dem sich die nächsten Generationen nach 2030 noch verhalten können, weil die Co2-Budgets einfach so knapp sind. Und dann sagt er eben, das Problem ist nicht, dass die Älteren so viel Positives für sich, die Dividende, rausgezogen haben, sondern dass sie, nachdem sie jetzt darüber aufgeklärt wurden, immer noch dabei bleiben wollen. Und da würde ich sagen, sie wurden ja noch gar nicht richtig aufgeklärt. Viele alte, also denen kann man wirklich noch was Neues erzählen, wenn man ihnen ihre Vorteile mal vor Augen führt. Und dann schreibt er ein Stück weiter, der demografische Wandel ist Folge von demografischen Entscheidungen, die die Älteren getroffen haben. Und das finde ich ein ganz super schwieriges Argument. Das ist ein bisschen, und da hat dann Merkel auch Recht auf der Bühne, wenn sie gefragt wird, naja, 2014, wieso haben sie denn da dem Putin nicht Einhalt geboten, als er die Grimme eroberte? Und dann sagt sie so, ja, wir haben dann noch mal die Verfahren und hier und so weiter. Wir wollten das alles einhegen, aber dann standen halt 2015 die Flüchtlinge hier in Europa. So, und wollen sie mir jetzt wirklich sagen, bei dem Stress, den wir 2015 hatten, sollten wir dann noch die Ukraine so behandeln, dass es auch über die öffentliche Meinung und so weiter bei Putin irgendwie ankommt? Und dann verstehen wir so ein bisschen, ne, stimmt. So historisiert, klar, sind wir jetzt 2022 alle total alarmiert, was die Ukraine angeht, aber 2015 waren wir zu einem ganz anderen Thema alarmiert. Und dann kriegt man solche Argumentationen nicht wieder hingebogen. Also hier zu sagen, die Alten haben damals demografische Entscheidungen falsch getroffen. Nein, die haben einfach politische Entscheidungen getroffen, die wir heute aus demografischer Sicht anders bewerten wollen und gerne einiges rückgängig, aber das ist halt nicht zu machen. Der Staat hat halt eben Pensionsversprechen abgegeben, die uns dann in 15 Jahren das Genick brechen. Und trotzdem muss man jetzt mit diesen Problemen aktuell klarkommen und kann nicht nochmal die Vergangenheit, wir haben keine Zeitmaschine, wir sind ja nicht im Marvel-Film oder so, wo wir nochmal entweder die Hälfte der Welt ausradieren oder in die Vergangenheit reisen. Das passt also nicht. Hier ist sozusagen keine handlungsleitende Ideengebung im Text drin, sondern wir können einfach nur entweder erzürnt darüber sein, dass es so ist oder halt, und so, ja gut, nochmal aufgeklärt werden. Aber das ist im Grunde dieses, das ist so ein Anti-Fitnessstudio. Hier wird uns nicht über Monate und Wochen so ein Fitnessstudio-Stein hingelegt, den wir dann immer ein paar Meter weiterheben und uns immer verbessern, sondern hier liegt auf einmal so ein Brocken vor uns, an dem wir einfach scheitern. Also hier findet kein Training oder sowas statt, sondern das ist einfach ein Wettkampf mit der Herausforderung, die wir nicht bestehen. Und dann lesen wir das in dem Buch und denken, also ist eh vorbei. So, und dann, und das finde ich ist sozusagen die große falsche Entscheidung in dem Buch, zu sagen, die Jüngeren wurden über das Klima-Thema politisiert. Und jetzt sollten wir diesen Konflikt, der da gerade ausgetragen wird, auch für die Generationenfrage nutzen. Und da würde ich sagen, ne, genau falsch gedacht. Der Klimadiskurs, den wir gerade führen, ist schon der Generationenkonflikt, aber eben nicht als Generationenkonflikt ausgetragen, sondern als Klimadiskurs. Wir hatten damals Luisa Neubauer im Aufwachen-Podcast. Und ich hab ihr auch, sie gefragt und ihr auch ein bisschen empfohlen, macht doch einen Generationenkonflikt draus. Und sie hat das damals total verneint, ganz vehement, ich hab's gar nicht verstanden. Heute, Jahre später, sage ich, oh man, zum Glück seid ihr mir nicht gefolgt und habt keine Generationen-Ding draus gemacht, sondern sind immer beim Klima geblieben. So können sich nämlich jetzt die Alten, was weiß ich, aufgeklärt, wie auch immer, urban leben, das Auto nicht brauchen und Urlaub sowieso, keine Lust, sich einfach mit den Jüngeren verbünden. Und so können auch die Jüngeren gegen die Jüngeren am Thema Klima sich abarbeiten. Denn das ist nun so weit, kann man es treiben. Auch das Klima ist keine Generationenfrage. Obwohl 90% des Klimabudgets von den Alten vor 20 Jahren verbraucht wurde, kämen wir trotzdem nicht weiter, wenn wir das runterbrechen auf ein Generationenproblem. Und so ist das auch für die Demografie selbst. Also nicht nur nicht das Klima, sondern auch die Demografie selbst. Dürfen wir nicht auf ein Generationen... Auch wenn es ganz paradox klingt, dürfen wir nicht auf ein Generationen-Ding runterbrechen.
Mir gefällt das sehr gut, was du sagst. Denn diese Konzentration auf Generationen, das ist etwas sehr Deterministisches in meinen Augen. Also was hat man denn wirklich mit der eigenen Generation zu tun? Und man kann natürlich, wenn man möchte, viel damit zu tun haben. Und gewisse Bedingtheiten sind da, die aber politischer Natur sind, nur ich habe mich mit meiner Generation nie identifizieren können. Ich habe mit 17, 18 gesagt, ich gehe jetzt in den Wagner-Verband. Da sind alle über 70, das sind nur noch vernünftige Leute. Gold behangen, sitzen sie da und reden über Wagner. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz angenehm. Und deswegen ist auch bis heute die Skepsis gegenüber der eigenen Generation die größte. Damit will ich auch vielleicht am wenigsten zu tun haben. Ich habe auch viel jüngere oder viel ältere Freunde. Und für mich ist es immer so verrückt, dass man glaubt, dass man mit einer Generation gleich sich selbst auch dann bestimmen kann. Sondern es ist ja auch gerade eine unglaubliche emanzipatorische Leistung, dass man sich vielleicht aus der Generation hinaus begibt und sagt, damit habe ich aber eigentlich gar nichts zu tun. Zugleich gibt es ja auch so eine Homogenisierung, die durch den Generationenbegriff stattfindet, die auch am Thema vorbeigeht. Denn es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass es die Generation Kreta gibt. Aber innerhalb der Generation Kreta, also in jener Generation, wo diese Alterskorte ist, sind ganz viele, die sagen, das Wichtigste ist für mich, dass ich ein schnelles Auto fahren kann und dass ich viele Reisen machen kann. Und außerdem will ich den größten Weber Grill der Welt kaufen. Das ist ja auch genau in dieser Alterskorte auch. Was sind das? Sind das eigentlich alte Junge? Oder wie will man sie bezeichnen? Und das ist eine so fatale Logik, wenn man da hinein verfällt. Und dann produziert man natürlich auch laufende Enttäuschungen, weil man dann immer glaubt, ach, jetzt hat die Generation es auch wieder leider nicht geschafft. Und jede Partei hat ja eine Jugendorganisation. Und da würde ich mal sagen, die Jugendorganisationen stehen sich da mitunter weit auseinander. Und ich glaube, das Problem ist hier, wenn ich diesen Blick auf die Gesellschaft werfe, dann kann ich am Ende nur zu so ganz offenen Formulierungen kommen, wie das dann auch hier im Buch zu finden ist. Dass man mal wieder miteinander spricht, dass man es als Querschnittsaufgabe bestimmt und auch begreift, dass man sich am Küchentisch trifft und über die Politik debattiert. Das sind alles so Sachen, da kann man sagen, ja oder nein oder es ist eigentlich auch egal, wie man es macht. Oder es ist so vollkommen unscharf durch den ganzen Text hindurch, dass man eigentlich hier so ein kleines Gebetbuch bekommt. Ja, wir müssten mal über die Generation nachdenken, vielleicht machen wir auch noch mal ein schönes Podium dazu, wo noch mal das eine oder andere gesagt wird. Vielleicht finden wir vier Leute, die aneinander vorbei reden. Das war es dann aber auch wieder. Ich hatte auch gedacht, ist das ein Buch? Das hätte 1994 erscheinen können. Ich glaube, bis auf ein paar aktuelle Bezüge hätte man das genauso auch schon schreiben können.
Genau, und es gab ja schon immer diese Generation-Thematisierungen. Olaf Scholz hat ja selbst im Bundestag noch mal behauptet, diejenigen, die das vor 20 Jahren schon meinten, sollen sich mal entschuldigen kommen und so. Da meint er bestimmt auch bis hin, und das ist dann wirklich philosophisch auch überdreht, das Methuselah-Komplott von Schirrmacher. Jetzt ist es allerdings so, trifft dich. Wenn man eine Definition macht, also ich werde die B-Bewegung mal wirklich definieren. Das ist Jahrgang 58 bis 71. Das sind die 13 Jahrgänge, die jeder für sich alle größer sind als alle anderen Jahrgänge vor 58 und nach 71. Also selbst der kleinste Baby-Boomer-Jahrgang ist noch größer als der größte Nicht-Baby-Boomer-Jahrgang. Wir haben es also mit einem richtigen demografischen Bauch, den wir in der Statistik, wenn wir uns ihn mal zeigen, auch sehen. Und trotzdem ist es super wichtig, nicht in die Generationen-Falle zu tappsen, sondern über Demografie zu schreiben, es politisch zu meinen und nicht zu sagen– und vielleicht erinnert sich jetzt der eine oder andere an unsere Mai-Besprechung– nicht zu sagen, die Generation muss aber dann auch zu 1 Million von dem Bundestag treten, um dort dem parlamentarischen Betrieb sozusagen Motivation zu sein, Motor zu sein. Das haben wir als Antipolitik dargestellt in Amerika. Wenn wirklich erst 1 Million Eltern nach Washington fahren müssen, um dort den Parlamentariern zu sagen, hört mal zu, wir wollen nicht, dass unsere Kinder weiter erschossen werden, macht mal ordentlich Waffengesetze, dann haben wir es schon mit einem Ausfall des politischen Betriebs zu tun. Dann brauchen wir diese 1 Million Menschen auf der Straße, die sich dann wieder… Dann reden wir nicht mehr von Politik, sondern das ist dann schon wieder das Volk selbst, das sich nicht repräsentieren lässt, sondern selbst tätig wird. Und darauf läuft ja dieses Buch hier hinaus.
Und es läuft natürlich auf etwas hinaus, was ich ja besonders liebe. Wir haben irgendwann mal diesen Bürgerrat besprochen. Damals von mir mit der Ansage, wir machen das jetzt einmal, damit wir es dann danach nie mehr tun müssen. Und hier wird so eine Art Bürgerrat vorgeschlagen, nämlich ein Jugendrat. Und der soll sich dann treffen und der soll auch angehört werden, vom Bundestag und von einzelnen Abgeordneten, die dann irgendwelche Schirmherrschaften übernehmen oder was weiß ich. Und es wird natürlich genauso sein wie bei diesen Bürgerratsexperimenten. Man gibt dann irgendein Thema vor, dann verfasst dieser Bürgerrat, dieser Jugendrat, irgendwelche Leitlinien und sagt, wir müssen auch eine andere Form des Kommunizierens miteinander finden. Und dann steht da drin, dass wir einen Ausgleich brauchen und dass die Wohnungsfrage uns alle umtreibt. Solche Sätze stehen dann da. Aber aus denen folgt natürlich nichts. Da sind dann Politiker sehr dankbar, dass man dann Fotos mit jungen Leuten machen kann, denn dadurch verjüngt man sich selbst auch noch mal ein bisschen. Und das war's. Also einen solchen stumpfen Vorschlag zu machen, also stumpf in dem Sinne, dass es nicht trifft, das finde ich schon sehr, sehr erstaunlich.
Ja, vor allem am Ende eine Nachzahlung bzw. Rückzahlung, für Klimaversäumnisse. Also nicht für Klimaschäden, sondern für jedes Lebensjahr, das man versäumt hat, gute Klimapolitik zu machen, wird man zur Kasse gebeten. Und da fragt man sich natürlich so ein bisschen, was ist denn, wenn man auch vorher schon nicht besonders auf der Gewinnerseite des Lebens stand? Soll man dann seinen individuellen Bankrott erklären, um dieser Nachzahlung nachzukommen? Und dann bezahlt man irgendwie einen dreijährigen Millionenerbe, nur weil er jung ist.
Da soll dann mal umverteilt werden, wo man die ganze Zeit kein Wort mal zu der enormen Ungleichheit in Deutschland liest. Und hier muss man ja auch noch mal ganz klar feststellen, wir haben Rentner, an denen geht es richtig gut. Und das ist auch zu erleben, wenn man so durch Deutschland reist. Die gehen da auch mit einer gewissen Attitüde durch den Bahnhof und so. Was kostet die Welt? Ich kann es mir leisten. Aber es gibt auch ganz viele, die können gerade mal so jetzt vielleicht mit dem neuen Euro-Ticket wohin reisen. Und sind ganz, ganz arg von Armut im Alter betroffen, was noch mal härter ist, weil da dann die wenigen sozialen Kontakte, die man noch hat, nicht aufrechterhalten werden können. Möglichkeiten, noch mal aus dieser Armut herauszukommen, durch irgendeine glückliche Fügung, durch Heirat oder durch einen Jobwechsel, sind alle nicht mehr gegeben. Das ist wirklich ganz bitter und trostlos. Und auch das ist kein Thema in diesem Buch.
Wir haben es beim letzten Mal thematisiert. Das Problem der Rentnerrepublik Ken, das ist auch in Italien Thema oder in Amerika wird es zunehmend, ist die Verteilung von Geld und Geselligkeit. Und das ist nicht einer Generation zuzuschreiben, sondern das finden wir in allen Generationen. Die Schülergeneration jetzt hat ja ihren 30 Prozent Sprung in den Inzidenzen, was die psychologischen Auffälligkeiten bis hin zu mindestens einer Suizidäußerung und so weiter oder Androhung angeht. Also diese Statistiken trudeln jetzt auch langsam ein. Die kommen leider auch für mein Buch schon wieder ein bisschen zu spät. Aber man konnte es ja super locker andeuten, weil man genau gesehen hat, was Corona bedeutet. Also dass aus 20 Prozent Prävalenz 30 Prozent werden für psychische Anfälligkeit. Jeder Dritte ist irgendwie krank. Im Studium verschärft sich das nochmal, insbesondere wenn die Unis nicht wirklich ordentlich zurückkehren zu Präsenzunterricht. Dann das Rausfallen aus der Arbeitswelt mit 65 Jahren. Plötzlich steht man ohne Kollegen da und weiß auch nicht so genau, was macht man jetzt den ganzen Tag? Man hat zu viel Zeit, aber eben auch zu wenig Geld. Geld korreliert da sehr scharf mit Geselligkeit. Schafft man sich den Kuchen zu kaufen oder nicht? Und sich da zu treffen. Und all das wurde hier in diesem Buch nicht thematisiert, weil man sich zu früh diese Generationenbrille aufgesetzt hat. Und das ist super schade. Gerade wenn man es ankündigt als philosophische Aufarbeitung, verliert man dann zu viel aus dem Blick. In der Hinsicht, und da würde ich sagen, du hast es jetzt schon zweifach angesprochen, ich mache es auch nochmal, diese Thematisierung der Schulden ist einfach grotesk. Denn es ist ja nun, er schreibt, die Jüngeren sollten einen überschuldenfinanzierten Klimaschutz als ungerecht kritisieren. Nein, ein überschuldenfinanzierter ist zumindest das, was wir dringend brauchen. Wie sonst sollte man ihn thematisieren? Und so wie er hier dieses ganze… Ich meine, du hast schon nicht so recht drüber lustig gemacht. Er guckt 200 Jahre in die Vergangenheit, um da irgendwelche Zitate zu finden. Wenn wir wirklich ein Buch schreiben auf der Höhe der Zeit, das sich mit Schicksalsvergemeinschaftung entlang des Alters usw. befasst, dann ist jetzt auch die Zeit, die Zäsur auszurufen und zu sagen, wir müssen nicht nur Geld anders verteilen, sondern auch die politischen Ideen. Und nicht nur sollten wir die Frage Schulden jetzt ja oder nein oder so, sondern diesen ganzen Diskurs sollten wir aussortieren. Das Geld ist einfach da, wenn wir es brauchen. Darauf müssen wir uns jetzt einigen. Und die Frage ist nur, kriegen wir eine Mehrheitsentscheidung hin in den parlamentarischen Prinzipien, die wir haben, denn die kriegen wir nicht so schnell revidiert oder revolutioniert oder wie auch immer, sondern der Bundestag arbeitet so, wie er arbeitet. Das wird er auch in 30, 40 Jahren noch tun. So, jetzt haben wir der 48 Jusos sitzen und eine 28-jährige Grünschefin und so weiter. Bekommen wir es irgendwie hin im Sinne von Stephanie Kelton zu sagen, ey, wir brauchen jetzt echt mal Geld für ein echtes Problem. Wir müssen uns einfach nur politisch entscheiden, dass wir es ausgeben wollen. Kriegen wir diese Entscheidung hin? Ja oder nein? Und wenn irgendwer nochmal über, oh, dann wächst aber der Schuldenberg, gerne in der Phoenix-Runde, wo keiner hinschaut oder so, kann man da stundenlang darüber diskutieren. Ja, aber wenn das Geld gebraucht wird, sollten wir uns das Geld einfach holen. Also diese Diskussion, dass man dann einfach…
Es ist auch eine so absurde Vorstellung. Also da merkt man, dass eigentlich der Klimawandel noch nicht eingetroffen ist beim Autor im Kopf. Denn das, was uns da jetzt blüht, ist ja so groß und so teuer, dass selbst wenn wir ganz, ganz sparsam wären und umverteilen würden, noch und nöcher und sagen würden, wir enteignen jetzt die Quanz und Klattens, dann würde das Geld ja nicht langen, um für den Klimawandel wirklich präpariert zu sein. Selbst das würde nicht ausreichen. Das heißt, die einzige Möglichkeit ist ja, nur über Schulden zu gehen. Wenn ich jetzt immer noch davon rede, wie können wir dann das da ausgleichen und so, das ist so eine Frage, das könnte man machen, wenn man jetzt Straßen ausbauen will und da kann man dann gucken, irgendwie können wir da einen Ausgleich. Ja, wenn es jetzt nur darum ginge, dann könnte man noch in diesem Modus verharrn. Aber wenn man die Größe des Phänomens Klimawandels wirklich ernst nimmt, dann muss man natürlich sagen, dass es nur über Schulden laufen kann. Es ist gar nicht anders denkbar. Also das wäre, ich will das mal vergleichen, obwohl ich ja sehr gegen diese Aufrüstung bin, aber ich will das mal sehr vergleichen. Wir haben jetzt diesen Haushalt, diesen Sonderhaushalt, 100 Milliarden und wir werden auch weiter aufrüsten, wenn dieses 2%-Ziel übererfüllen. Das wäre jetzt genauso, wenn Scholz gesagt hätte, liebe Leute, Metall und Silber schickt es ein, wir kochen das alles ein und machen einen Kanon raus. Da würde jeder sagen, gut, jetzt ist er übergeschnappt. Und das ist aber eine ähnliche Vorstellung, wenn man sagt, gut, wir müssen da jetzt nochmal gucken mit dem Lastenausgleich und wie können wir das da generationengerecht mit dem Klimawandel, präparieren, präpariert sein für den Klimawandel und ein Kampf gegen den Klimawandel kostet sehr viel Geld. Und da braucht man sich keine Generationenfragen oder sonst was mehr stellen. Entweder macht man das jetzt oder man lässt es. Und dann wird es aber alles noch sehr viel schlimmer. Dann verschärfen sich all die genannten Probleme noch mehr.
Ja, also alles richtig. Ich will es trotzdem nochmal um eine Stufe strapazieren. In der Soziologie, der ich anhänge, Niklas Lumans Systemtheorie und nicht nur dort, ist Geld ein symbolisch generalisiertes Kommunikationsmedium. Als Erfolgsmedium tituliert, weil es zu Sachen motiviert. Wir denken da gar nicht drüber nach im Alltag, aber wir gehen an eine Supermarktkarte. Wir brauchen eine Minute, um uns einen Liter Milch zu kaufen. Die Komplexität, die dahintersteckt, die kriegen wir gar nicht in unseren Kopf rein. Vor 200 Jahren musste man dafür noch, man brauchte noch eine Kuh. Die Kuh musste im richtigen Zustand sein. Man musste die Kuh vorher füttern. Nur so kam man zu einem Liter Milch. Heute reicht es, 69 Cent, so billig ist es, im Supermarkt einfach hinzulegen. Man muss nicht mal mit jemandem reden. Alle wissen, was zu tun ist, nämlich einen Liter Milch aushändigen. Jetzt sind wir superreich und haben ein supergroßes Problem. Global, also gesellschaftlich betrachtet. Wir in Deutschland sind superreich und wir haben ein sehr großes Problem, Klimawandel. Noch könnten wir die Klimaprobleme so lösen, dass Geld als Medium reicht. Wir haben jetzt schon Beispiele gesehen. Die Inflation zeigt uns, dass Geld irgendwann nicht mehr reicht. Dass wir irgendwann nur noch Geld haben und feststellen, blöd. Dafür können wir uns keinen Klimaschutz mehr kaufen. So wie man in England feststellte, wir haben eine politische Entscheidung getroffen und jetzt haben wir zwar wahnsinnig viel Geld, aber es fährt trotzdem keiner den Lkw. Und man muss ihn doppelt so viel und dreimal so viel Geld bieten.
Die Leute aus der City of London gehen nicht plötzlich in den Lkw und sagen, dann fahren wir halt.
Genau, das ist eine richtige Wirtschaftskrise. Wirtschaftskrise ist bei uns immer so, wenn viele zu wenig Geld haben und dann hungern oder so. Eine richtige Wirtschaftskrise ist, wenn ganz schön viele ganz schön viel Geld haben und trotzdem nichts passiert. Und das ist eine ganz große Gefahr, dass wir irgendwann an diesen Kipppunkt kommen, wo wir feststellen, ich habe zwar jetzt eine Million Immobilie und zwei Millionen auf dem Konto, aber mir baut niemand eine Solaranlage aufs Dach, weil kein Handwerker da ist. Und das Zeug auch nicht aus China her angeliefert wird. Und dieses Problem droht eigentlich. Und das ist zu behandeln. Klimawandel und demografischer Wandel sind jetzt noch zu lösen, solange es wir noch mit Geld organisieren können. Irgendwann fällt das aus. Irgendwann kriegen wir das nicht mehr mit Geld organisiert und wir haben dafür keinen Ersatz. Das ist die große Gefahr. Dass wir einfach nur noch ganz orientierungslos dastehen und uns das Geld einfach... Es gibt diesen Satz, ja, irgendwann wird man feststellen, dass man Geld nicht essen kann und so weiter. Ihr kennt ihn alle. Das droht uns. Das ist die Gefahr, die hier abzuwenden ist. Und da wird Johannes Müller-Salo der ganzen Problemlage einfach nicht gerecht. Das muss man hier ganz deutlich sagen. Obwohl er, und das finde ich auch gut, Demografie und Klima zumindest problematisch miteinander verkoppelt, um das in einen Text unterzubringen. Aber das eigentliche Problem wird hier weder thematisiert noch gelöst. Aber gut, lösen muss man es auch nicht. Aber zumindest thematisieren muss man es jetzt endlich, damit es dann in zehn Jahren oder so spätestens mal ordentlich angegangen wird.
Diagnostisch ist es aber interessant, weil ich glaube, dass das jetzt hier nicht ein Einzelfall ist oder die Ausnahme ist, was wir hier gelesen haben. Sondern ich glaube, wenn man jetzt in Talkshows solche Generationenfragen verhandelt sieht, dann ist das auf einem ähnlichen Niveau, weil man nicht bereit ist, über Funktionalitäten des Systems zu sprechen. Man nicht bereit ist, über Geld wirklich zu sprechen, in einer sinnvollen Weise. Und weil man, glaube ich, auch nicht in der Lage ist, in so einer Klarheit, die natürlich in gewisser Weise auch bitter ist, darüber zu sprechen. Sondern man will das dann doch immer noch mal alles ein bisschen einbetten, in ein bisschen Philosophie und ein bisschen Gefühl. Und jeder kann irgendwie auch in seinem Sentiment, wie man sich so als Angehöriger einer Generation fühlt, abgeholt werden. Dass das etwas ist, was wir eigentlich permanent, also seit ich mich an Debatten über Rente, Generationenkonflikte oder so erinnern kann, ist das eigentlich immer das. Das ist so ein Geplätscher. Da könnte ich, also ich sehe auch schon so vor mir, dass da noch mal gesinne Schwan sitzt, die dann auch noch mal irgendwie was erzählt, wie wir über Zukunft nachdenken sollten. Und das ist so ganz schön dann für so eine Bundesrepublik, die aus der ersten Klasse im ICE mal raus stolpert und dann ein Podium sich anhört. Aber eigentlich ist das, ja, glaube ich, ein Symptom für den Stand der Diskussion.
Das stimmt. Es gibt so viel Grund, über Demografie und Klima noch mal zu schreiben, obwohl es schon so viel gibt, weil wir so viel, das haben wir auch schon häufiger kritisiert, unoriginelles dahingeplappert haben, wo einfach noch mal die Substantive in anderen Wort-Satz-Bauarten zusammen, aber im Grunde ist es immer dasselbe. Naja, da hilft uns dieses Buch also wenig weiter, weshalb wir es hier auch Dennis Scheg-Lyke hinabgleiten lassen.
Ja, wir lassen es hinuntergleiten. Nicht konkret, nicht philosophisch, nicht vertiefend, nicht aufgeklärt spricht Johannes Müller-Salo im Buch Offene Rechnungen über den kalten Konflikt der Generationen. Er ist leider nicht in der Lage, über die ökonomischen Bedingtheiten in einer modernen Weise nachzudenken. Und so ist dieses Buch vielleicht ein Bewerbungsschreiben für die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung, mehr aber nicht.
Ja, man kann viel über das Thema quatschen. Das macht er ja auch. Es ist das allgemeinige Quassel. Die Substantive sind alle bekannt. Vor allem Rente. Aber über Demografie schreiben, ohne in die Generationen-Falle zu tapsen und das Klima als Problem noch ordentlich einzukassieren, das ist schwer. Daran kann man scheitern. Das ist dann schade. Aber wenn es passiert, ist es wie es ist. Dieses Buch ist leider an seiner eigenen Fragestellung gescheitert.
Wir gehen weiter zu einem Buch von Catherine Liu mit dem Titel Virtual Harders, The Case Against the Professional Managerial Class. PMC, das ist ein Begriff, der ist schon mal aufgetaucht bei dem Buch Das Ende vom Ende der Geschichte. Das ist eine Klasse, die wir erst ganz kurz spezifizieren müssen, was ist damit gemeint. Es muss vielleicht noch mal zurückgegangen werden zu Siegfried Krakauer, erlaube mir diesen kleinen Exkurs. Siegfried Krakauer beobachtet in den 20er Jahren, dass da eine neue Klasse entstanden ist, nämlich die Klasse der Angestellten. Die Angestellten sind keine Arbeiter, sondern die Angestellten sind zum Beispiel Sekretärinnen oder irgendwelche einfachen Buchhalter. Die leben meistens im städtischen Raum. Das Buch von Krakauer konzentriert sich auch sehr auf Berlin. Wenn man das literarisch einmal nachvollziehen will, dann muss man das Kunstseidende Mädchen oder Gilgi lesen von Irmgard Coyne. Und diese Klasse der Angestellten ist eine, die glaubt, dass sie nicht Arbeiterklasse ist, will auch mit der Arbeiterklasse, mit diesem Milieu, mit dieser Kultur nichts zu tun haben, träumt, denkt und arbeitet sich auch ein bisschen nach oben, tritt gerne nach unten, paktiert eher mit dem Chef. Es gibt bei Krakauer so eine Szene, da ist eine Sekretärin, die von ihrem Chef eingeladen wird, am Abend in irgendein Restaurant. Und dann ist da eine Garderobiere, und diese einfache Sekretärin gibt der Garderobiere ihren Mantel, aber nicht im Sinne von, das ist jetzt einfach diese Dienstleistung, sondern von oben herab, so als würde sie, die Sekretärin, auf die Garderobiere von oben herablegen, weil sie ja jetzt ausgeführt wird gerade. Und diese Verblendung, dass man also glaubt, eigentlich ganz oben zu stehen, das ist etwas, was Krakauer in seinem Buch beschreibt. Und dann in den 60er-Jahren, 70er-Jahren sind es amerikanische Soziologen und auch Journalisten, die diese professionelle Manager-Klasse versuchen zu bestimmen. Und diese Klasse ist auch wiederum eine Angestelltenklasse. Aber wir sprechen hier nicht von der einfachen Sekretärin oder dem Buchhalter, sondern wir sprechen von dem, sagen wir, Marketing-Chef einer Abteilung. Das kann aber auch der brillante Journalist sein, der für eine große Zeitung schreibt. Das können irgendwelche Leute in den Medien sein. Das können Leute sein, die einen pädagogischen Abschluss haben und jetzt aber in der Personalabteilung sitzen und dort die Leute raussuchen. Also diese Klasse wird da beschrieben. Die gehören also zu den oberen zehn Prozent, aber nicht zu den wirklich reichen. Sie besitzen selbst nicht die Produktionsmittel. Sie haben keine Unternehmen.
Das ist auch der wichtige Punkt hier, glaube ich.
Genau. Sie besitzen nicht die Produktionsmittel. Sie arbeiten hier in Deutschland, würde man vielleicht sagen, die arbeiten bei Siemens, bei Jung von Matt, bei RTL, ProSieben, wo auch immer. Aber sie haben dann auch eine tolle Position. Sie verdienen auch ordentlich Geld. Nicht superreich, aber schon ordentlich Geld. Und diese Klasse hamstert Tugend für sich. Daher kommt auch dieser Titel. Und diese Klasse will nichts mit denen da unten zu tun haben, verachtet die. Der Ausdruck von den Deplorables, den Hillary Clinton geprägt hat, den überträgt Catherine Liu auf diese ganze Klasse. So blicken die eigentlich auf die da unten, die Martial Arts Fight sich ansehen oder so. Und sie sind es, die das System stabilisieren, die also die ganze Zeit den Chefs, den Kapitalisten zuarbeiten und versuchen, nach unten sich abzudichten und einen Arbeitskampf und auch einen Klassenkampf niemals zuzulassen. Das ist also erst mal die Grundüberlegung dieser PMC-Definition. Und du bist aber mit dem Buch, wie man es dir ansieht, nicht zufrieden.
Wie es sich ja eben schon herausstellte, mag ich ja, wenn Bücher einfach mit so einem klaren Definitionskatalog beginnen und man einfach weiß, worum geht es ja eigentlich, was wird hier thematisiert. Man kann ja dann immer noch alle politischen Problematisierungen mal richtig ausformulieren, aber zumindest die Grundlage des Fundaments sollte gelegt sein. Das fand ich ja noch ganz gut, denn es ist wirklich immer ein bisschen klar, PMC und so, gerade auch, ich habe es ja beim letzten Mal schon uns wurde das empfohlen als das etwas klügere Wagenknechtbuch, die selbstgerechten, das finden wir ja wieder, aber das ist halt auch so eine schwammige Sache. Aber wir können eben klar sagen, es sind die leitenden Angestellten, die vielleicht noch über diese Vorzugsaktien, die ja immer so einen besonderen Namen Vorzugsaktien am Unternehmenserfolg beteiligt werden, aber über diesen Eigentum, diesen finanziellen Eigentum, den sie da erwerben, nicht in die Eigentümerklasse aufrücken, sondern sie arbeiten für jemand, der sie engagiert. Also selbst wenn sie Aktien des Unternehmens, das kennen wir ja aus dem Silicon Valley und so weiter, haben, heißt das erst mal nur finanzieller Spielraum. Sie dürfen nicht wirklich mitentscheiden, wie sich dieses Unternehmen entwickelt. Und es sind sozusagen die obersten Verdienste bei keiner wirklichen, und dann dieses schöne Marksbild, die Produktionsstätten sind ihnen, was das angeht, bleiben ihnen dann doch verschlossen. Und ich finde, wenn man das Fundament einmal so gelegt hat, kann man wirklich viel schreiben. Sarah Wagenknecht hat ihr Buch ja nicht ohne Grund geschrieben, auch wenn sie es dann schlecht geschrieben hat. Aber man weiß halt, warum es ein schlechtes Buch ist, weil man so eine Idee von einem besseren Buch hätte irgendwie. Und in diesem Fall von Catherine Liu haben wir es ja mit einer Polemik zu tun, die nun wirklich von Anfang an, so wie du auch manchmal, wenn du Bücher besprichst, erst mit dem Urteil und dann den Argumentationen kommst, so ist das ja hier auch. Es ist ja schon völlig klar bei ihr, welches Bild sie da hat. Dann spielt sie so ein bisschen mit dieser Zuschreibung. Schreibt dann eben, wenn sie dieses Buch lesen, gehören sie auch zur PMC. Aber wahrscheinlich haben sie auch schon so ein ambivalentes Verhältnis. Deswegen hole ich sie jetzt mal da ab.
Sie gehört ja auch selbst dazu, die Autorin natürlich als Professorin.
Genau, versucht dann so eine Aufklärung über sich und den Leser selbst herzustellen. Aber mir sind diese Angriffe und dann auch wieder diese Stereotypen zu scharf. Und dann nützt es auch wenig, das hat ja Wagenknecht auch gemacht, immer wieder in den Text reinzuschreiben. So privilegiert sind sie ja gar nicht. Es sind ja einfach nur diese Signale und so weiter, um die es da geht. Aber es sind ja keine wirklichen Privilegien. Also die spielen sich ja auch viel vor. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich hab's wahnsinnig ungern gelesen. Ich kam nicht so richtig vorwärts auch im Text.
Also ich hab's mit großer Freude gelesen. Ich fand manche Kapitel nicht ganz so stark wie zum Beispiel das über Sex. Fand ich viel zu dürftig. Also da hätte man auch viel Interessanteres sich rausnehmen können.
Deswegen steht es ja auch so am Ende.
Ja, ja, es ist so angefügt, man wollte noch ein paar Seiten offenbar schreiben. Das hat mich auch nicht interessiert. Aber was doch ganz erstaunlich an diesem Buch ist, ist, dass man erst mal sagt, man muss konstatieren, dass nach 68 sich etwas wandelt. Nämlich, dass diese Klasse dann einen enormen Aufstieg erlebt und auch die Lebensstile dieser Klasse oder der Lebensstil der Klasse dann der Hegemoniale wird. Was nicht heißt, dass alle diesen Lebensstil pflegen, aber man muss sich daran orientieren. Und wenn man diesen Lebensstil dieser PMC-Klasse nicht hat, dann muss man sich vorwerfen, dass man rückschrittlich ist, dass man nicht so kultiviert ist. Und dass zugleich auch eine fast religiöse Bindung entsteht, die also in gewisser Weise kontraintuitiv ist. Denn wir haben es ja damit einer Klasse zu tun, die natürlich auf kirchliche Autoritäten pfeift, aber sich so eine eigene Religion dann zusammen bastelt, die vor allem sehr tugendhaft ist und auch eine Religion, die so aussieht, dass diese Klasse sich als auserwählt begreift. Und das hat doch wieder an Michael Sandel erinnert. Michael Sandel kritisiert hier die meritokratische Gesellschaft, die glaubt, man kann durch Leistung einen Aufstieg schaffen. Und die Leistung muss auch das entscheidende Kriterium sein in der Bewertung von Lebensläufen, von beruflichem Erfolg und auch von Entlohnung. Und das ist etwas, wo er sagt, es produziert permanent Verlierer, produziert eigentlich all das, was wir dann mit Trump ganz transparent gesehen haben. Und da knüpft sie, ohne Sandel zu nennen, ja eigentlich an, indem sie sagt, diese PMC ist ja dieser meritokratischen Ideologie komplett erlegen und sieht sich auch tatsächlich als wahnsinnig fortschrittlich und auch moralisch gut und außerwelt an. Denn sonst hätten sie es ja auch gar nicht geschafft. Und sonst wären sie ja nicht die. Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel, ich will wirklich, also mir ist es zu widerfasst, weil es so banal ist. Aber ich mache es trotzdem. Ich will das mal aufgreifen mit diesem Böllerverbot, weil wir weil daran kann man es glaube ich ganz gut nachvollziehen. Ich finde diese Debatten, ich will mich eigentlich mit intellektuellen Dingen ausnahmsetzen, nicht mehr zum Unsinn. Aber ich will dieses Böllerverbot jetzt trotzdem mal nennen. Wir haben seit Jahr und Tag haben wir dieses Böllerverbot Thema. Und natürlich wird dieses Böllerverbot eingefordert von den PMC-Leuten. Das sind Leute, die in urbanen Räumen, Silvesterfeiern in Restaurants, die so teuer sind, dass die meisten Leute da nicht reinkommen und die sagen, guck dir das Pack da draußen an mit ihren China-Böllern. Ich war immer auf Seiten der Leute, die böllern, auch wenn das ökologisch nicht gut ist und vielleicht ein bisschen gefährlich oder weiß ich nicht was. Aber ich habe diesen Snobismus immer gehasst und der ist aber ganz ausgeprägt und der ist auch ausgeprägt bei vielen, die eine Anti-Auto-Altung haben. Und ich bin sehr für die Verkehrswende. Aber was wir momentan im Diskurs erleben, ist, dass wir Leute haben in der ländlichen Bevölkerung, es sind nicht wie Ulrike Herrmann sagt, fünf Prozent, die auf ein Auto angewiesen sind, sondern ein Großteil in Deutschland ist auf ein Auto angewiesen. Dass die jetzt dargestellt werden als die Dreckssteuern der Nation, von Leuten, von denen ich bei Twitter, ich nenne keine Namen, von denen ich weiß, dass die drei, vier Flüge im Jahr machen. Und von Leuten, wo ich weiß, die fahren Auto, die sind ein Zehnjahr nicht geflogen. Das ist diese Elite, die hier geschildert wird und die als PMC hier bezeichnet wird. Und ich habe da eine große Sympathie für diese Leute, die sich diesem Diskurs nicht stellen. Und ich fand es auch noch mal, sie kommt ja mehrmals auf Corona kurz zu sprechen. Wir haben es ja selbst gesagt, Stefan, es war die PMC-Klasse, die bei Twitter geschrieben hat, Homeoffice für alle, wo sie nie darüber nachgedacht haben, dass ganz viele Berufe, zum Beispiel Paketbote sein, Metzger sein, nicht im Homeoffice zu machen sind, sondern sie müssen alle raus, damit wir die Podcaster, Grafikdesigner und Fernsehmaskottchen zu Hause rumhängen können.
Ja, also ich habe gar nichts gegen die Inhalte. Wie gesagt, mir geht es in diesem Text um den Ton, denn das Problem, was sie ja auch behandelt und eigentlich thematisieren möchte, ist ja, die Linke kommt ja gar nicht vorwärts. Sie geht ja diesen Wahlkampf durch. Elizabeth Warren war die Heldin der PMC, ist dann gescheitert. Man hat sich nicht rechtzeitig hinter Bernie Sanders versammelt und damit ist das dann auch versandelt. Und plötzlich musste man doch wieder mit Joe Biden leben und so weiter. Und du hast das Jahr 68, das ist bei ihr auch die Zäsur, wo sich die PMC so von der Arbeiterklasse abwendet und dem Kapital zuwendet, beispielsweise über diese komische Aktienbeteiligung am Unternehmensgewinn. Also man fühlt sich dann auf der falschen Seite und so weiter und so fort. Und dann haben wir eben jetzt diese Problemlage, dass wir auf der einen Seite diese PMC haben, die die Working Class so richtig runtergerockt haben. Das sieht man ja auch, wie sie wohnt, wen sie verdrängt und so weiter. Und gleichzeitig unterstellt man dann der Working Class, sie haben ja gar keine Kultur. Ja, wie auch. Wenn man ihnen alles genommen hat, dann bleibt halt wenig Kulturmöglichkeit übrig. Und statt da jetzt einfach solidarisch einzugreifen und zu helfen, also wirklich so ein genossenschaftliches Wohnen oder was auch immer, so die unsere Stadt, die Stadt gehört uns, solche politischen Wege zu gehen, überzieht man sie mit so einem Wokeness-War, mit Moralpanik, also mit moralischer Panik, mit Pseudopolitiks, also Politik, die gar nicht wirklich Politik ist, wie zum Beispiel das Böllerverbot. Das ist ja auch wirklich nur Pseudo in diesem Maße.
Das ist ja vollkommen hirnrissig, ob man es macht oder nicht.
Genau, so wie man Strohhalme aus Papier nur noch verkaufen darf, aber die dürfen dann wiederum in Plastik eingepackt sein und der ganze Blödsinn, der sich halt so zieht. So, und dann haben wir jetzt aktuell, und deswegen tauchen ja auch solche Bücher jetzt auf, diese Problemlage, dass wir diese quasi politisierten PMC, die völlig in die falsche Richtung abgebogen sind und noch die Working Class im Stich lassen, nicht vorwärts kommen, während gleichzeitig die Right-Wing-Commentators die PMC-Sachen so weaponisen in der politischen Debatte. Also die ganzen Ressentiments. Das, was die PMC über die Working Class nur so denkt und andeutet, sagt halt Donald Trump einfach so richtig deutlich, aber dann wie über der Bande gespielt, so dass es wieder ein Argument gegen die PMC ist, in dem man nämlich aufgreift, ihr seid die Verlierer, aber wählt mich doch trotzdem. Donald Trump stand ja vor den Schwarzen und hat gesagt, was habt ihr denn noch zu verlieren, wählt mich doch einfach. Schlimmer als demokratische Politik kann meine Politik für euch gar nicht sein. Und dann haben viele, oh, scheiße, das stimmt irgendwie. So. Und das ist ja diese Problemlage, in der wir drinstecken. Und da würde ich aber sagen, gibt es jetzt zwei Wege, das zu thematisieren. Entweder Kapitel 2 Sende. Wir gehen dann wirklich zu Recht Jahrhunderte zurück ins politische und geistige Denken und schauen uns an, wo ist denn die Ursache dafür, dass wir heute so ein Leistungsprinzip haben. Ah, und dann kommt irgendwas mit dem Kalvinismus und so weiter. Und wir haben das ja gelobt und rekapituliert und gesagt, das ist genau die Heuristik, die wir brauchen. Oder wir überziehen das Ganze eben nochmal mit so einem Wognis im Quadrat-Polemik-Schleier und legen dann so ein Buch vor. Und da muss ich sagen, es hat mir wenig geholfen. So sehr ich das inhaltlich alles unterstütze, das war allerdings auch bei Wagenknecht schon so. Trotzdem hat mir das Buch nicht gefallen. Hier sind jetzt andere Gründe. Es ist leider, finde ich, so in der Methodik einfach der falsche Weg. Die Leute wollen jetzt auch mal, und damit meine ich mich, aber wir haben es auch bei Merkel gesehen, die redet immer auf der Bühne von Mann. Mann hat es nicht besser gekonnt, aber sie meinte ich. Was mir an Sendel gut gefallen hat, ist dieser Mangel an Zynismus, an Wokeness, an diesem ganzen modernen Theater, Medientheater, das wir die ganze Zeit erleiden und selbst auch miterleben und mitgestalten. Und da ist mir dieses Buch einfach zu, keine Ahnung, das ist so ermüdend auch, immer wieder graben zu müssen, nach diesen guten Argumenten unter dieser Partie.
Ja, es ist konfrontativ und dadurch verstellt man auch den Blick für die eigentliche Argumentation, die ja immer wieder aufblitzt. Du hast es gerade gesagt, warum sind die Rechten so erfolgreich? Naja, sie haben erkannt, tatsächlich führt die PMC einen Kulturkampf gegen alles, was sich vor Flachbildschirmen versammelt und Fliesentisch. Genau, solche Sachen. Ja, also das und da hat man immer wieder ein neues Rüstzeug. Sie erwähnt ja schon die Maske hier. Das haben wir ja auch dann. Das aber ein sehr deutsches Phänomen dann noch mal so bei Twitter. Auch im Mai 2022 kann man noch mal Likes abgreifen, indem man sagt, und ich fahre immer noch, egal wohin, mit 27 3M-Masken übereinander und so weiter. Also wir kennen das ja dann. Und diese Tugendbolde sind ja dann auch bei der Ukraine sofort in die entsprechende Richtung gelaufen und haben sich da auch sehr tugendhaft gegeben, ohne in irgendeiner Weise politisch rational über die Sache zu reden. Aber das reicht, wenn man einfach die Tugend signalisiert. Und das erkennen die Rechten und sagen, guckt, bei uns braucht ihr das nichts zu machen. Wir ärgern die jetzt mit euch mit. Die Piesacken euch jetzt schon seit Jahrzehnten mit, wie ihr euch verhalten sollt, wo ihr zu vulgär seid, wo ihr irgendwo Böller losgelassen habt. Wir ärgern die jetzt. Wir machen jetzt Politik gegen die PMC. Und das soll den Leuten, die nicht zu PMC gehören, signalisieren, dass hier von den Rechten Politik für die einfachen Leute gemacht wird. Das stimmt aber nicht. Es wird nur Politik gegen die PMC-Leute gemacht, was auch schon ganz lustig sein kann. Aber das verbessert in keiner Weise die ökonomische Situation. Und um die geht es ja eigentlich. Und um die ist ja auch Catherine Liu bemüht. Diese Situation bleibt dieselbe. Man sagt nur, aber wenigstens diesen Kulturkampf, diesen Irren, da stellen wir uns jetzt mal auf eure Seite. Denn wir lieben durchaus auch das Vulgäre. Und bei uns kann auch noch gesagt werden, was man so sagen will. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz fatale Situation, in der wir uns da befinden. Und das arbeitet sie auch gut heraus. Aber es stimmt natürlich, wenn man nur auf diesem konfrontativen Kurs ist, dann kommt man nicht auf ein Niveau, wie das Michael Zendel gelingt. Also ganz klar.
Auch hier hätte man beispielsweise mal durchzählen können, indem man sagt, okay, entweder wir machen jetzt eine ganz zynische Selbstreflektion. Ich sage, ich gehöre selbst zur PMC und schreibe dann darüber. Oder anschließend an das, was du jetzt aufgedröselt hast. Also man erkennt plötzlich die PMC, erkennt plötzlich die Working Class, weil sie von der Gegenseite, von den Rechten, von den Neurechten mobilisiert werden. Und dann, und das fehlt im Buch, könnte man ja wirklich darüber schreiben, darüber sich aufklären, wie viel das eigentlich sind. Plötzlich haben ja die PMC festgestellt, wie groß die Working Class eigentlich ist, die angesprochen wird von, dass da 70, 80 Millionen Amerikaner bereit sind, Trump zu wählen. Selbst nach einem ersten 4-Jahres-Versuch mit Trump sind die davon nicht abgeschreckt. Und das sollte ja nun wirklich dann aufschrecken, findet aber nicht statt. Trotzdem, ich finde die Kapitelfolge irgendwie ganz gut. Also dieses Transcrashing, the boundaries of professionalism. Sie kommt auf Ellen Sokals zu sprechen, den ich auch nicht kannte, der 1997.
Ach so, das muss man vielleicht ein bisschen erklären. Weil das ist ja ein ganz interessanter Vorfall gewesen, der bis heute die Postmoderne zerrüttet hat. Und zwar gab es ja zu Zeiten der 90er-Jahre so einen postmodernen Hype auch dann in Amerika. Das ist ja mit ein bisschen Verspätung Ende 70er, Anfang 80er von Frankreich eingetroffen in den USA. Um das mal jetzt ein bisschen abgekürzt zu sagen, es hat in Deutschland alles ein bisschen schneller ist, das vonstatten gegangen. Im Übrigen gibt es ja einen, über den wir heute noch sprechen werden, der versucht hat auch zu verhindern, dass diese französische Postmoderne hier in Deutschland Fussball-Fassassen waren, nämlich Jürgen Habermas und sein großer Derrida-Streit. Jedenfalls Derrida, Bodria und so weiter wurden sehr stark in Amerika rezipiert. Und daraufhin entstanden auch dann diese Cultural Studies und in Zuge dessen auch Gender Studies und so weiter. Und da sind sehr viele Texte dann produziert worden im Sinne dieses poststrukturalistischen, postmodernen Denkens. Und daraufhin ist dann Alan Sokol hingegangen, der eigentlich ein Linker ist, wie ich dann hier nochmal erfahren habe, der dann einen Dada-Text geschrieben hat. Und zwar irgendwas über Quantum-Physik und Inklusion und die westliche Wahrheitssegumonie ist passé. Und das war einfach nur ein Text, der aus Versatzstücken aus irgendwelchen poststrukturalistischen Texten stand. Den hat er eingesandt bei einer an sich renommierten postmodernen Zeitschrift. Die haben den gedruckt. Und dann Monate später hat dann Zockel gesagt, nee, das war eigentlich nur ein großer Joke. Und damit hat er gezeigt, dass Wahrheit überhaupt keine Rolle mehr dazu spielen scheint. Da hat er aber auch gezeigt, die haben sich in so einem sprachspielerischen Diskurs inzwischen verirrt, dass die jeglichen Bezug zu irgendeiner sinnvollen Wissenschaft verloren haben. Und man kann das jetzt sehr kritisieren. Dass es vielleicht auch eine verkürzte Darstellung dann von Zockel war oder der Effekt dann vielleicht doch nicht nur so aufschlussreich ist, wie das so angenommen wird. Aber was doch ganz interessant ist, dass sie hier nochmal aufzeigt, man hatte eigentlich an den amerikanischen Universitäten unter den radikalen Linken einen Diskurs hergestellt, der sich wirklich nicht mehr um Fragen der Ökonomie kümmerte, weil man den Marxismus vollkommen aussortiert hat und damit auch den Sozialismus, also als eine Möglichkeit, wie kann man Gesellschaft anders aufbauen, vollkommen ausrangiert hat. Wie das ja auch in Frankreich der Fall war. Foucault tritt an als Professor, wendet sich erstmal von Althuis Seer, einem Marxisten, einen französischen Marxisten, was nochmal was besonderes ab. Und dann geht man in diese Identitätspolitik und all diese Dinge rein. Es ist jetzt alles ein bisschen verkürzt, aber was hier nochmal so deutlich wird an diesen Punkten ist, dass man da diesen Kontakt ganz willentlich aufgibt zur Arbeiterklasse und sagt, damit wollen wir nichts mehr zu tun haben. Thomas Frank hat das dann mal in seinem Buch geschrieben. Es ist ein bisschen so, als würden Meeresbiologen immer noch forschen, aber hätten dann irgendwann vergessen, dass das ja alles im Meer spielt. Also das Wasser, also die Ökonomie, die alles umfließt, die hat man einfach ausgeblendet.
Genau, und das passt natürlich ganz wunderbar, also diese Kapitelentscheidung, das so zu strukturieren. Weil von 96, also Sokal schreibt diesen Text, Realität ist Kreation, Objektivität ist Fassade. Im Grunde wird die ganze Geisteswissenschaft einmal demoliert. Es bleibt quasi nichts übrig. Gleichzeitig beginnt allerdings diese Clinton-Regierungen so richtig zu fruchten. Sozialpolitik wird so verkürzt auf, wir machen das jetzt mal so übergangsweise, geben wir dir noch ein bisschen Geld. Aber im Grunde ist es schon dein eigenes Schicksal, wenn du aus dem Berufsleben rausfällst. Die Bildungskosten explodieren, die Wohnkosten explodieren. Und am Ende liegt alles dann nieder. Also man hat weder eine Geisteswissenschaft, die noch irgendwie, und ich würde es mal nicht nur auf Marx verkürzen, aber sich irgendwie für Ökonomie oder Realität interessiert, für Fragestellung. Gleichzeitig rauscht aber die Realität einmal in der ganzen Härte so richtig rein und dann, zwölf Jahre später, um mal nur so einen Pseudozeltrahmen zu nennen, ist halt Crash in Amerika. Und alle stehen nackt da, sowohl finanziell als auch was sich in Ideenhaushalten angeht. Und darauf folgt dieses Kapitel über The PMC Has Children. Und da kommt sie auf Doktor Spock zu sprechen. Den kennst du jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht. Nein, den kenne ich schon nicht. Denn ich habe mir, als mein erstes Kind geboren wurde, auch mir die Frage gestellt, was mache ich jetzt mit dem Kind? Ich stellte sie heraus, in Amerika gibt es ein Buch, das sie über Jahrzehnte mehr verkaufe als die Bibel. Jeder, der ein Kind hat, kriegt dieses Doktor Spock Buch geschenkt. Es ist also ein tausendseitiges Buch, das über die Jahre auch gewachsen ist. Es ist der Ursprungsautor Doktor Spock, der ist schon eine Weile tot. Und dann hat er so ein Komitee übernommen, um das irgendwie aktuell zu halten und so. Also eine richtige Institution für alle, die rein wachsen in die Gesellschaft mit Kindern. Und dieses Buch soll dich eigentlich wieder zurückführen, dazu intuitiv an die Sache ranzugehen. Man erwartet zu viele Antworten und kriegt dann einfach nur ein ja beobachtet doch mal dein Kind. Wenn sich heute anders als gestern verhält, dann zieh mal Schlüsse da draußen so. Also soll dich eigentlich wieder zurückführen. Und das fand ich irgendwie gut platziert, hier nochmal diesen Hinweis zu geben, während die ganze junge Eltern-Schar total oh man, wann muss ich jetzt die Geige kaufen? Reicht das schon mit drei Jahren? Oder sollte ich sie mit zwei Jahren schon anschaffen? Also dieses Ganze, was ja auch immer so übertrieben dargestellt wird, die Helikopter-Eltern und so weiter und so fort, ist so dieser Dr. Spock dazwischen. Allerdings schlägt dann auch die Polemik dazu. Sie kommt dann wie Sendel nochmal auf diesen Uni-Zugangsskandal. Man hat dann doch nicht so viel Dr. Spock gelesen, sondern alle haben dann nochmal sogar über Trügereien versucht, das Beste für ihr Kind rauszuholen. Natürlich immer auf Kosten anderer Kinder. Das ist ja immer eine ganz wichtige Sache. Die man da thematisieren muss. Und dieser ökonomische Stress allgemein der Eltern vererbt sich eben auch auf die Kinder. Wir haben also doch es mit so einer verzogenen nächsten Generation zu tun, der wir immer weniger politisches Lösungswillen und Vermögen sozusagen unterstellen wollen. Also die PMC in der Falle, möchte man fast sagen, sehen wir hier. Und na klar, da macht sich diesen interessanten Appell. Um den kommt dann weniger drum rum. Ich habe den auch drin. Wir brauchen eine Familienpolitik, die die Eltern entlastet. Also die wirklich mal sagt, klar das Kind wird nicht mal von einem Dorf erzogen, sondern jetzt, wie wäre es von einer ganzen Gesellschaft? Stattdessen nein, Kindergärten haben keine Betreuung mehr. Also ganz aktuell, es leuchten Leute schon wieder die Glocken hier. Aber meine Nachbarin arbeitet als Berufslehrerin.
Das ist nur noch die Simulation von Dürflichkeit.
Ja, genau, ich habe den V schon ein bisschen ausgeschaltet heute, aber die Glocken sind jetzt da. Also eine meiner Nachbarinnen arbeitet als Berufsschullehrerin und arbeitet jetzt freiwillig ehrenamtlich einen Tag die Woche in ihrem Kindergarten, damit dort überhaupt noch Betrieb stattfinden kann. Und sie macht es ehrenamtlich, also lässt sich auch diesen einen Tag nicht bezahlen, weil sie dann erst wieder bei ihrer Berufsschule, also dem Staat, anfragen müsste, darf ich jetzt da noch zuarbeiten und so weiter. Also der Staat fällt aus als derjenige, der einem die Kinderbetreuung organisiert. Und gleichzeitig traut man sich als Staatsangestellte nicht, den Staat zumindest, ja, bei diesem kann ich dann wenigstens diesen Tag, den ich dann im Kindergarten bin, noch Zuverdienstgelten machen, da traut man sich, den Staat nicht auf den Senkel zu gehen. Das ist mittlerweile dieser PMC-Zustand gerade. Also man nimmt wirklich alles hin und versucht jedes politische Ding einfach zu vermeiden. Die Hauptsache, es geht noch irgendwie weiter. Man hört bei mir auch schon den Willen zur Polemik raus, aber die funktionalen Argumente müssen hier, finde ich, doch dringender nach vorne geschoben werden, damit man mal wieder zu Handlungsvermögen kommt. Na ja, und dann hat sie sich nochmal an Obama abgearbeitet.
Obama liest und das fand ich eigentlich ganz schön. Sie macht da nochmal eine kleine Rehlektüre von diesem ganz berühmten Buch von Harper Lee. Und das ist doch ganz interessant, dass wir es mit einem Präsidenten ja zu tun hatten bei Obama, der angetreten war, tatsächlich die soziale Situation zu verbessern. Und dann hatte er das aber nicht gemacht. Er hat eigentlich alles so weiter laufen lassen, hat schöne Reden gehalten und all das. Und dann ist er im Ruhestand, ist nicht mehr Präsident und präsentiert sich dann auch gar nicht als jemand, der vielleicht mal einsieht, wo die großen Fehler begangen sind, sondern wir bekommen dann so Porträts vom lesenden Obama, der sich in Bücher vertieft, was ich ja sehr schätze. Und wir haben jetzt gerade bei Merkel gehört, sie macht das jetzt auch, jetzt hat sie auch dafür Zeit, es scheint wohl so ein Muster zu sein. Und was liest er dann? Wer die Nachtigall stört. Und nun ist dieser Harper-Li-Roman für mich immer, na ja, so ein bisschen sentimentales Ding gewesen. Ich hab also dieses Phänomen nie so ganz verstanden. Also ich konnte das zeithistorisch einordnen, aber ich hab's als literarisches Werk nie so recht verstanden. Und jetzt wird hier so eine Rehlektüre unternommen. Wie werden eigentlich hier die einfachen Leute dargestellt, also die, die rassistisch sind in dem Buch. Und wie das eigentlich die PMC bis heute prägt mit ihrem Blick auf die einfache Klasse. Und sie hat ja schon vorher so eine tolle Passage, wo sie schreibt, The PMC saw the classes below them through the eyes of the ruling class, and they could not distance themselves fast enough from the immiserated poor. As downward social mobility became a terrifying reality, poor people were increasingly seen as the monstrous other. Und das monströse andere, das ist ja fast psychoanalytisch hier gesprochen, dass man da sieht, das ist tatsächlich in Harper Lee's Roman auch schon da. Und das können wir aber auch in der Populärkultur immer wieder finden. Und das finden wir auch in diesem klassistischen Diskurs, den wir aus dem Reality-Fernsehen kennen. Wir haben das ganz stark gehabt übrigens, als die Hartz-IV-Reformen eingebracht wurden. Da hatten wir fast jeden Abend irgendeine Sendung im Fernsehen, wo uns gezeigt wurde, Gott, wie monströs anders diese Leute sind. Die arbeiten nicht, die stopfen den ganzen Tag, Zigaretten sitzen auf der Couch. Also diese Bilder, die da imaginiert werden. Und das ist etwas, was sie hier nochmal dann mithilfe dieser Lektüre versucht, herauszuarbeiten. Und das finde ich gelingt ja auch gut. Nun muss man sagen, das ist dann jetzt auch schon wieder ein bisschen spezialistisch. Also man muss, wer die Nachtigall stört, gelesen haben, um das, glaube ich, dann so im Ganzen nachvollziehen zu können. Aber was ich sagen muss, ist, dass es doch von ihr so einen Wunsch gibt, nach einem anderen Blick auf die Leute, die nicht zu PMC gehören. Aber sie kann auch nicht so recht definieren, wie müsste denn eigentlich dann eine sinnvolle Kultur aussehen? Also ich kann jetzt natürlich sagen, alles ist gut. Also ich kann sagen, toll, der eine guckt gerne Martial Arts auf dem Flat-Screen, der andere geht in die Oper. Ich kann das alles so nebeneinander stehen lassen. Aber man kann ja auch mal fragen, was ist eigentlich auch ökonomisch passiert, dass sich keine sinnvolle Kultur ausbilden konnte. Denn es war ja, und sie ist ja für ein sozialistisches Programm, es war ja mal ein sozialistisches Programm auch, dass Arbeiter ins Theater gehen, Bibliotheken und Arbeiter in Betriebsbibliotheken auch ein großes Thema. Jacques Rancière hat dazu ja viel geschrieben in Frankreich. Und da, finde ich, müsste es dann auch mal das ein oder andere Konkrete geben, was man mal hervorhebt, wie denn eine andere Gesellschaft aussehen könnte. Also ich will ja keine Vision haben jetzt von einem Gesellschaftsentwurf, so soll es sein, aber dass man einfach immer nur beschreibt, ja, die PMC verachten das und das und das. Das reicht nicht aus, wenn man sagt, wie könnte dann eine Kultur der Arbeiterklasse, die sie hier stark machen will, aussehen?
Genau, ja, also für mich endet das Buch da auch irgendwie Obama, Traum der Liberalen, der wahr wurde, jemand, der sich von 0 auf 100 hochgearbeitet hat, und dann das noch mal sozusagen nur als Posterboy benutzt wurde. Tja, dieses Abarbeiten an Common Core, also diesen Bildungsstandards, die man da hat, also ins Theater gehen wäre schön, aber schon in der Schule mangelt es ja irgendwie an Fortschritte, die man rein organisiert. Die Education Reform, die Lehrer wurden bestraft für Schülerergebnisse, also in deren Sicht eine schöne innerliche Aufarbeitung von den ganzen Problemstellen. Was steht in dem Kapitel? Ich hab's nun wirklich...
Na, da geht es um diese Thematisierung von sexueller Belästigung bzw. auch Vergewaltigung auf dem Universitätscampus. Sie fragt sich, wie das so das dominante Thema werden konnte, wenn wir über Sex sprechen, da das ja auch wiederum nur die Leute überhaupt betrifft, die an Universitäten sind. Und dass auch diese ganzen anderen Fragen der sexuellen Emanzipation und Befreiung und was eigentlich lieber Tinasch heißt, dann nicht auftauchen. Ich finde, das Kapitel allerdings ist ziemlich schwach dann doch geworden. Also man kann da sicherlich die eine oder anderen Strangen nachvollziehen und auch das ist hier dann zu beobachten. Aber ich würde sagen, da kann man über Sex und PMC mehr nachdenken. Interessant ist vielleicht eine Feststellung in diesem Kapitel, die sofort uns auch auffällt, glaube ich, wenn wir so um uns herumblicken. Und zwar ist ja es so, dass die 68er-Generation und auch die Nachfolgende, jetzt denke ich auch schon Generation, aber also die, die damals so studentisch unterwegs waren und so weiter, die Liebe befreien wollten, den Sex befreien wollten, lieber Tinasch wollten. Und da sagt sie erst einmal, naja, der Ursprung dieser Lieber Tinasche ist eigentlich bei Marquis de Sade zu finden. Und das bedeutet aber dann auch wirklich das Abseitige der Sexualität zu sehen. Das will ich jetzt mal weglassen. Interessanter scheint mir, dass sie dann sagt, ja, das haben die da alles gemacht und gefordert. Und dann ist aber interessant, dass es gleich so einen akademischen Diskurs gab, der nicht sagte, wir haben jetzt befreit Sex, sondern wir brauchen ganz viel Wissen über Sex. Wir müssen jetzt unsere Geschlechtsteile ganz gut kennen und wir müssen wissen, welche Stellungen es gibt und wir müssen das wissenschaftlich betreiben. Diese Verwissenschaftlichung aber, und hier macht sie eigentlich ein Foucault-Argument, diese Verwissenschaftlichung hat aber eigentlich schon wieder den Sex domestiziert. So hat man Bücher geschrieben über das Wissen über Sex, aber hat eigentlich keinen Sex gehabt bzw. hat sich dann in ganz bürgerliche Beziehungen begeben, hat geheiratet, vielleicht zwei Kinder gezeugt und das war's. Also Libertinage war da nicht. Wenn noch irgendwo Libertinage zu finden ist und auf die blicken aber dann die PMC wieder herab, dann ist es bei der Arbeitenbevölkerung, die haben eine höhere Scheidungsrate, da ist mehr Sex außerhalb der Ehe und so weiter. Und das findet sie erstmal sehr interessant, dass da diese Libertinage ist. Oder eine verstellte Libertinage, aber sie arbeitet das dann nicht weiter heraus. Ich finde nur noch im Schluss eines ganz interessant, in dem sie schreibt, und hier kommen zwei Sachen zusammen. Die ich sehr wichtig finde. Nämlich diese PMC funktioniert zum einen über soziale Konformität. Was muss ich jetzt gerade über Masken denken? Ah ja, man muss Maske tragen, sonst ist man kein fortschrittlicher, progressiver Mensch. Genau. Und gleichzeitig, und das finde ich bemerkenswert, beschreibt sie ja hier, dass diese Klasse ja total fragmentiert ist. Da gibt es den Wettbewerb, und da gibt es die Individualisierung. Und je größer diese Fragmentalisierung ist, desto stärker ist die soziale Konformität, weil man versucht dadurch noch so etwas wie eine Gemeinschaft herzustellen, die aber eigentlich nicht gegeben ist, die sich dann nur noch so als ad hoc-Gemeinschaft bei Twitter unter einem Hashtag findet. Aber du weißt ja immer gerne mal wieder darauf hin, dass es nicht das Leben ist, wenn man das Leben leben will. Da muss man Twitter verlassen und jetzt mal zur Tür herausgehen. Und dann erlebt man sich aber eigentlich als Fragmentiertes.
Genau, da ist man dann nur in seinen Rollen. Die muss man dann entsprechend darstellen. Da ist ja auch Svenja Flasspöhler mit ihrem Argument oder ihrer Argumentation zur neuen Sensibilität ganz nah dran. Nur weil wir so immer kleinere Korridore der Toleranz haben, werden die Abweichungen immer deutlicher thematisiert. Obwohl sie eigentlich immer kleiner werden. Und darüber dann auch dieser ganze soziale Stress, der daraus führt. Wenn man so ein Wogness war, einmal begonnen hat, dann kommt man da halt auch nicht wieder raus. Den kriegt man auch nur schwer ins Stolpern.
Wie ist es denn? Du bist ja jetzt jemand, der Wagenknecht, Flasspöhler und Catherine Liu gelesen hat.
Ich will mal eine Antwort schon mal vorbereiten.
Nein, nein, nein, sag mir nicht, was soll man lesen? Und du sagst Sendel, da stimme ich ja direkt zu. Aber wenn man jetzt von den dreien sich einen Text aussuchen sollte, dann ist es doch wahrscheinlich Catherine Liu, oder?
Warte mal, ich will nicht zu schnell antworten. Also die Flasspöhler und die Wagenknecht, die sind ja selber, also die beziehen ja Position in einem gewissen Sinne, dass sie nämlich sympathisieren und ihnen auch immer wieder nachgesagt wird. Das sind ja fast die Argumenten der neuen Rechten. Und sei es nur die runtergedimmten, medial transportierten, die uns bei Fokus oder bei Bild und so begegnen. Und da fällt ja die Christine Liu, auch wenn wir jetzt ihren Diskurs, wo sie so drinsteckt, nicht so richtig verfolgen. Dass es andere, also schon regional andere Diskurse sind. Ein bisschen wahrscheinlich raus.
Komplett würde ich sogar sagen. Also ich glaube, sie kann damit gar nichts anfangen. Und sagt das ja auch am Anfang und am Ende, wo sie sich eigentlich positioniert. Das heißt, sie will eigentlich das Sanders-Lager stark machen. Mit dem, mit diesem ganzen anderen Unsinn nicht zu tun haben.
Aber auch da wieder, weil du jetzt Sanders angesprochen hast, diese Abneigung gegen Elizabeth Warren und diese Hinwendung zu Sanders ist ja auch Beispiel für diese Fragmentierung. Denn die beiden sind durchaus auch unter einen Hut zu kriegen, wenn man sich den gesamten politischen Diskurs anschaut. Diese Differenzen, die da vorliegen, sind marginal. Und trotzdem ihre klare Positionierung. Ich würde sagen, man findet bei Flassböhler die interessantesten Argumentationen, Herleitung, bei Wagenknecht die interessanteste politische Positionierung der Autorin. Und bei der Catherine Liu findet man wahrscheinlich so die beste Polemik, wenn einem das liegt. Also so wie du, wenn man jetzt so deinem Leserlebnis, wie du es gestildert hast, folgt, scheint es ja eine gewisse Attraktivität zu haben, diese Polemik dann auch mal so richtig aufzusaugen. Und wenn das Angebot da ist im Buch, 80 Seiten, kann man es ja auch annehmen, ohne dass man sich jetzt da so in die Irre führen lässt.
Ich habe es während einer Zugfahrt gelesen und es war natürlich Wasser auf meinen Mühlen, aber das macht ja nichts. Warum will man ja auch, dass die Räder gut laufen?
Genau, also wenn man durch so einen Text dann gut durchkommt, wenn das sozusagen der Motor des Lesens ist, gut. Wenn es einen immer wieder so ein bisschen rauswirft und man sich so denkt, ach ja, klar, klar, Catherine, aber... Also in der Ansicht kann ich sagen, alle drei haben so gewisse Vorzüge und viele, viele Nachteile.
Sie sind keine Kapitalisten, aber sie glauben, solche zu sein und auch so mächtig zu sein. Die PMC, die professionelle Managerklasse, also die leitenden Angestellten, sind vor allem Tugendhamsterer. Und diese Tugend, die haben sie so ausgebaut, dass daraus ein Lebensstil geworden ist, an dem sich alle orientieren sollen. Dagegen polemisiert, heftig, aber durchaus amüsant, Catherine Liu in ihrem Buch Virtue Hordas und plädiert für eine neue Linke, die sich von diesem Tugendwahn abwendet.
Ja, und wer, und das kann man sich dann selbst den Test unterziehen, glaubt, von Narzissmus hypnotisiert zu sein, bekäme dann hier die entsprechende Aufklärung. Sie rante drum, wünscht sich aber doch eine zivile Debatte, da fällt auch vieles auseinander. Aber wer weiß, ein Buch, das man sich als Spiegel vorhalten kann.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen. Wir machen weiter mit Paul Mason, Publizist, Autor des Buchs Postkapitalismus. Ein Buch, das ich nicht über alle Maßen schätze. Dann hat er ein Buch geschrieben, Klare lichte Zukunft. Und nun hat er sich gesagt, ich muss unbedingt Jürgen Habermas antworten. Das können wir nicht durchgehen lassen, was Habermas da in seinem Essay, den wir im letzten Salon besprochen haben, geschrieben hat zum Krieg. Und zwar erinnern wir uns, Habermas sagt, wir sind da in einer sehr schwierigen Situation. Wir haben uns entschieden, nicht Kriegspartei zu werden. Wir müssen die nukleare Bedrohung immer mitdenken. Wir müssen deswegen sehr vorsichtig sein, dass wir nicht doch Kriegspartei werden. Und wir müssen aber auch erkennen, dass wir in einer ganz heiklen Situation sind, wenn wir sagen, waffen den Ukrainern und die Ukrainer, die kämpfen so mutig und toll. Denn wir sind immer dann auf der Zuschauerloge. Und da ist es dann doch bequemer, als direkt im Kriege zu sein. Und diese Ambivalenz, dieser können wir uns gar nicht entziehen. Nun haben wir Paul Mason, der sagt, ich habe die Idee einer postheroischen Mentalität nie akzeptieren können. 1960 geboren rebellierte ich früh gegen meine katholische Erziehung. Mit 16 wurde ich Marxist, mit 19 nahm ich an Massenstreiks teil und mit 62 kämpfe ich noch immer gegen Neoliberalismus, Totalitarismus, Faschismus und den modernen Überwachungsstaat. Und da würde ich sagen, das hat erstmal mit der postheroischen Gesellschaft nicht allzu viel zu tun. Die postheroische Gesellschaft sagt ja erst einmal aus, dass wir nicht mehr in einen Krieg ziehen, in dem wir bereit sind, uns für ein höheres Prinzip wie das Vaterland zu opfern, und zwar unser Leben zu lassen dafür. Dass da mit jegliches Engagement wegfällt, ist erstmal damit nicht ausgesagt. Zumal ja auch die Frage ist, wenn man sich an Massenstreiks beteiligt, ob man dann gleich viel opfert wie derjenige, der sein Leben auf dem Schlachtfelde für das Vaterland opfert. Und die Antwort ist natürlich ganz klar, ne, da ist ein erheblicher Unterschied. Und es ist sicherlich aber auch ein Signum der postheroischen Zeit, in der wir leben, dass Aktivismus sehr schnell an Grenzen gerät, wo es Opferbereitschaft verlangt. Und es muss ja nicht immer gleich das Leben sein, aber wir haben ja zum Beispiel im Zuge von 68 auch Leute gehabt, die haben in Kauf genommen, dass ihr beruflicher Weg ihnen verwehrt bleibt aufgrund des radikalen Erlasses. Und trotzdem fanden sie es gut, sich zu engagieren. Würde man heute sich noch engagieren mit dem Wissen, dass dann der berufliche Weg unmöglich wird? Ich bin mir da unsicher. Ich würde zumindest sagen, bei linken Aktivisten ist das so gut wie nicht mehr anzutreffen, mit wenigen Ausnahmen. Also auch da kann man schon eine postheroische Gesellschaft diagnostizieren. Nun schreibt Paul Mason folgendes. Jürgen Habermas stellt fest, dass die Existenz nuklearer Waffen und die damit verbundene Drohung gegenseitiger Vernichtung konventionell geführter Kriege unmöglich macht und dass es in diesem Szenario keinen Sieg mehr geben kann. Derselben Logik folgend hätten wir den Widerstand gegen die moderne, global vernetzte Bourgeoisie mit ihrer zunehmend militärisch aufgerüsteten Polizei und digitaler Überwachung auch gar nicht erst aufnehmen können. Und jetzt, also Paul Mason würde sich vermutlich auch selbst als Philosoph verstehen. Was sagt er hier eigentlich? Also ja, Habermas hat schon recht, diese nukleare Bedrohung gibt es. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass man nicht trotzdem sich engagiert in diesem Krieg, dass man tatsächlich zum Beispiel Kriegspartei wird. Denn schließlich haben wir ja auch gegen die global vernetzte Bourgeoisie gekämpft, obwohl die ja auch eine militärisch aufgerüstete Polizei hat. Und ja, es gibt Polizeigewalt und ja, wir können da auch in Deutschland seit G20-Gipfel und so weiter ein Lied von singen. Aber das ist ja nicht vergleichbar mit einem nuklearen Angriff. Also das hier zusammenzubringen, zu sagen, ja, wir sind aber auch auf die Straße gegangen, obwohl da Hundertschaften von Polizisten standen, als wir gegen Setscher auf die Straße gingen, ist ja nun wirklich nicht vergleichbar mit der Frage, na, sollen wir mal gucken, ob es einen Atomkrieg gibt. Also das ist einfach schon so unredlich, dass man eigentlich hier, wenn man nicht einen Podcast betreiben würde, die Lektüre abbrechen könnte.
Das fällt mir eh häufiger auf. Das ist so eine Hypo-Normalisierung oder Hypo-Sensibilisierung für dieses, ach, Putin hat schon wieder mit Atomwaffen gedroht, ja, macht er ja eh nicht. Ja, so eine Haltung gibt. Die Geschichte des Kalten Krieges ist diese Geschichte der Abschreckung über Jahrzehnte. Und wir sind jetzt schon in so einem, ah ja, macht er schon seit drei Monaten und so langweilig langsam. Ja, also dass man die Atomwaffen so wegmarginalisiert. Klar, werden die beobachtet und die sind auch nicht von jetzt auf gleich einsetzbar und so weiter. Aber die Drohung ist ja dann trotzdem eine Drohung mit entsprechenden Handlungsfolgen, die klar, auch wenn sie nicht passieren. Ja, also du hast es ja schon mal aufgegriffen. There is no glory in prevention. Dieser Satz gilt jetzt auch. Ja, also der gilt, der galt nicht nur bei Corona, sondern der gilt jetzt auch. Also wir haben immer noch einen Atomkrieg verhindert und das sollte man auch nicht zu gering schätzen.
Ja, aber zwei Seiten in der Frankfurter Rundschau überschrieben mit, wenn wir keine Untoten werden wollen, denn das ist der Vorwurf, wenn wir jetzt nicht uns entsprechend da engagieren, dann werden wir selbst zu Zombies, ist dann auch wirklich, also ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das nennen soll. Es steht dann da und ich will es nur machen, weil Paul Mason so bekannt ist und weil er Bestseller schreibt und überall eingeladen wird und ich einfach diese Niveaulosigkeit kaum mehr tragen kann. Er schreibt dann, aber Habermas liegt falsch, wenn er daraus folgert, dass konventionelle Kriege gegen eine Atommacht nicht gewonnen werden können. Doch, da liegt Habermas sehr richtig. Und er hat Unrecht, wenn er behauptet, dass Deutschland in der welthistorischen neuen Ära nach dem 24. Februar seinen friedensbewahrenen Fokus aufrechterhalten kann. Denn dies ist nicht einfach irgendein Widerstand eines Landes gegen die Aggression eines anderen. Dies ist nicht einfach ein Krieg, bei dem es um das ethnische und nationale Überleben der Ukrainer gegen einen vom Faschismus inspirierten russischen Ethnonationalismus geht. Es ist ein systemischer Konflikt, sagt er jetzt. Und dieser systemische Konflikt sieht so aus, was im Visier ist, ist eine totalitäre Welt unter russisch-chinesischer Vorherrschaft. Das sei der eigentliche Konflikt, in dem wir uns befinden. Russland will sich das Recht vorbehalten, selbst zu entscheiden, wo seine Macht endet und so weiter. Und wenn wir jetzt erst mal weiter denken, also dieser systemische Konflikt, der hier gezeigt wird, und der wird ja auch von beiden immer wieder angesprochen. Was kann denn für uns daraus folgen? Für Paul Mason ist ganz klar, jetzt Engagement, jetzt Waffenlieferung und am besten mitkämpfen. Also er sagt es dann nicht, dass wir eigentlich ja dann selbst Kriegspartei werden müssten, wenn man es wirklich ernst nimmt. Aber eigentlich folgt das ja daraus. Er fragt dann auch, sind wir bereit, die Unterstützung der demokratischen Opposition innerhalb dieser Staaten aufzugeben? Sind wir bereit, ihre Forderungen nach einem Ende der internationalen Rechtsordnung zu akzeptieren? Sind wir bereit, ganze Länder, Völker und Sprachen von ihren ethnonationalistischen Eroberungszügen vernichten zu lassen? Und er zieht hier immer auf Russland und China ab. Nachher kommt auch noch Indien hinzu in diese Argumentation. Und er vergleicht dann die Haltung Deutschlands jetzt und die Haltung Habermas mit der Appeasement-Politik der 30er-Jahre, was ich sehr falsch finde, das in dieser Weise zu verkürzen. Und dann sagt er, dass man auch zwar Habermas Recht geben muss, dass wir natürlich Putin nicht nach Den Haag bringen können, weil man dafür ja erstmal das Gericht in Den Haag von Seiten Russlands und der USA akzeptieren müsste, legitimieren müsste. Aber er sagt, das mag zwar sein, aber die Russen selbst könnten Putin in Moskau auf den Manegeplatz bringen, wo ihn dasselbe Schicksal wie Benito Mussolini ereilen könnte. Ja, das kann ich natürlich mir ausmalen, aber ich sehe diesen russischen Widerstand nicht, der kurz davor ist, dann Putin zu exekutieren. Also das ist einfach nur Geschwätz. Das ist einfach nur Geschwätz.
Genau. Und wir haben eigentlich diese rote Linie auch aus bekannten Gründen, dass wir, wenn Russland im Ausland einen Krieg führt, wir trotzdem keine innere russische Politik machen, vor allem nicht über Empfehlungen und so weiter. Sondern wir können nur von außen mit Sanktionen hineinwirken, aber das müssen die Russen dann schon selber entscheiden.
Ja, er diagnostiziert dann in Deutschland zwei unterschiedliche Sichtweisen. Und zwar ist die eine jene entstanden in der Vergangenheit, sie ging davon aus, dass eine friedliche Koexistenz mit dem autoritären Kapitalismus Russlands oder China möglich sei. So, das wäre dann das, was man jetzt als Merkels Politik bezeichnen könnte. Die andere, die in den letzten fünf bis zehn Jahren entwickelt wurde, geht davon aus, dass das gesamte Denken der Aufklärung, die Demokratie und die internationale Weltordnung nach 1945 davon abhängt, dass Staaten, die aggressiv, totalitär oder ethnonationalistisch werden, moralisch, politisch und wenn notwendig auch militärisch besiegt werden müssen. Und da bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher, ob es diese andere Sichtweise gibt. Es gibt die Sichtweise eins, die da geschildert wurde. Wir gucken mal, ob das ganz gut geht, wenn wir das mit denen machen, denn unsere Wirtschaft profitiert davon. Und dann gibt es die andere Sichtweise, die sagt, nee, wir müssen uns davon losmachen. Und es geht auch nicht, dass wir Profite auf Kosten von Menschenrechtsverletzungen in China machen. Aber das heißt nicht, dass wir, wenn notwendig, auch militärisch China besiegen wollen. Denn das können wir uns ja abschminken. Also das kann ich ja sogar wollen, aber es ist ja einfach nicht realistisch. Wie soll das aussehen? Sollen jetzt USA und EU gemeinsam, Russland, China und Indien platt machen, weil uns die Wertvorstellungen dort nicht passen? Beziehungsweise ja, die entsprechen nicht den Menschenrechten, wie wir sie definiert haben und wie die Menschenrechte sind. Also ich will das auch gar nicht relativieren. Die entsprechen so nicht. Aber das ist eine Gegebenheit, mit der ich in irgendeiner Weise umgehen muss. Denn ich kann es nicht ändern. Also ich kann sagen, ich kann meine Politik zu den Ländern ändern. Ich kann versuchen, möglichst viele Flüchtlinge aus diesen Ländern aufzunehmen. Das sind alles Politiken, die ich betreiben kann. Aber ich kann nicht sagen, ich will jetzt gerne mal diese drei Großmächte da besiegen, denn so passt mir das nicht. Da sind wir einfach machtlos. Und er ist aber in so einem, und das finde ich so bezeichnend daran, er ist zwar 62, aber eigentlich in so einem ganz primitiven Aktivismus gefangen, wie man das jungen Leuten vielleicht noch entschuldigen würde, dass er sagt, jetzt mal alle auf die Straße und jetzt ab morgen die gerechte Gesellschaft. Und das führt dann so weit, dass er dann sagt, auch Deutschland muss das Risiko eines unprovozierten nuklearen Erstschlags auf die Ukraine als reale Möglichkeit akzeptieren und bereit sein, darauf mit allen verfügbaren Mitteln konventioneller Kriegsführung zu reagieren. Wie soll denn da noch eine konventionelle Kriegsführung aussehen, wenn der nukleare Erstschlag begonnen hat? Da laufen ja Automatismen dann ab, die hier einfach ausgeblendet werden. Und es geht dann so weit, dass er noch mal deutlich macht, weil eine Welt, die von Xi, Putin, Modi und einem weiteren Trump kontrolliert wird, den Klimawandel nicht bekämpfen wird, weil das die langsame Zerstörung unseres Planeten zur Folge haben wird. Hinzu kommt, dass eine solche Welt im Schatten totalitärer Staatschefs allmählich auch eine totalitäre Gesellschaft hervorbringen wird. Ja, wegen mir alles richtig, nur was sollen wir tun? Also wenn hier das so angedeutet wird, ein weiterer Trump, dann befinden sich Großbritannien mit der EU bald im Krieg gegen Xi, Putin, Modi und Trump. Das machen wir dann oder wie? Ja, also, ich bin, ja, man ist, man ist, und es ist aber so eine ganz komische Empowerment-Logik. Also er ist natürlich in diesem Aktivismus und das merkt man dann auch, dass bei ihm dann nachher alles so zusammen gerührt wird. Also wir haben jetzt ja schon gehört, wir müssen uns gegen diese ganzen autoritären Führer stellen und dann sind einfach alle Kämpfe, wo irgendwelche Leute für irgendwas aufstehen, werden bei ihm alle gleich. Also das geht dann nachher so weit, dass er schreibt. Aber natürlich habe auch ich Angst davor, was ein solcher Kampf bedeuten würde. So wie ich Angst hatte, als die britischen Minenarbeiter einen potentiell selbstmörderischen Kampf gegen Setscher aufnahmen. Als die Südafrikaner in Soweto gegen die Apartheid aufstanden und als ich junge Palästinenser in Gaserstein in Richtung israelischer Soldaten werfen sah. Im Übrigen, Israel wäre ja ein Verbündeter im Kampf gegen diese Autoritäten, die er da anführt. Also es ist so krude zusammengerührt und ich warne wirklich vor diesem, sich moralisch auf der richtigen Seite wählenden Aktivismus, denn der scheint mir ja gefährlicher zu sein als als alles andere. Also wo wirklich jetzt einmal jemand aus so einer rein militäristischen Logik oder so heraus argumentiert, da kann man sich noch gut dagegen stellen. Aber wo das hier darum geht, wo man sagt, ja, wenn du noch irgendwas spüren willst, wenn du kein Untoter sein willst, dann hast du jetzt aber hier diese Kriege zu entfachen, auch wenn es den nuklearen Erstschlag dann für uns bedeuten könnte. Ich finde es katastrophal, dass solche Texte von jemand erscheinen, der sich dann auch noch als links ausgibt.
Vielleicht können wir ihn einordnen, woran wir anschließend an das, was wir vorhin schon besprachen, Formsalon. Fatalismus und trotzdem politische Auseinandersetzung als kognitives Fitnessstudio. Paul Mason ist ja nun eigentlich bekannt dafür, so ein Labour-Anhänger zu sein, der für Labour auf die Straße geht, viel für Jeremy Corbyn gekämpft hat und so weiter. Und wir sehen ja, in welchem Zustand England gerade ist und wohin Paul Masons Aktivismus bislang nicht führte in England. Ja. Und jetzt können wir einen Brückenschlag machen.
Sehr richtig.
Wenn er jetzt so eine Idee hat für die Welt, sollten wir der folgen, so wie er der Labour-Idee gefolgt ist. Wir sehen ja, wie Chris Dahmer sich da gerade abarbeitet. Und das letzte, was man hat, ist noch so ein bisschen die Queen. Denn Boris Johnson hat ja auch sein Misstrauensvotum da überstanden. In der Hinsicht immer schön, in Alternativen zu denken. Denn wir kennen ja die alte Lenin-Logik. Es lohnt sich nur, für eine bessere Idee zu kämpfen. Und nicht, weil man eine schlechte hat und die nicht mehr haben will. Also man braucht eine Alternative. Das hat man ja in Deutschland eingebaut. Das ist das konstruktive Misstrauensvotum. Solange in England niemand zur Verfügung steht, der es stattdessen macht, bleibt man auch lieber bei Boris Johnson. In der Hinsicht sollte Paul Mason vielleicht doch noch mal Bilanz seines eigenen aktivistischen, publizistischen Schaffens ziehen und sich dann fragen, traue ich mich jetzt auf diese große Bühne? Denn mit dieser großen Publikumsmacht geht doch immer Verantwortung einher. Und dann kann man uns nicht alle so in den Krieg tricksen jetzt. Also ich fühle mich auch zu viel in den Krieg getrickst. Aus vielerlei Richtungen. Und jetzt hast du uns noch eine weitere Facette dargeboten. Bleiben wir aber aktivistisch im Letter in Support of Responsible Fintech Policy schreiben 26 namenhafte Autoren unter der URL concerned.tech. Also man ist beunruhigt und möchte hier doch mal den einen oder anderen Hinweis dalassen. Zu denen, deswegen bin ich drauf gestoßen, weil es Corridor Doctor mitverteilt hat und mitunterschrieben hat. Und Bruce Schneier. Bruce Schneier ist ja für mich immer so der, okay, wenn es jetzt irgendwie uns so kryptomäßig, dann ist Bruce Schneier immer so die letzte Passion. Sein Urteil zählt dann immer über Sachen, bei denen man selber null Skin in the Game hat. Also wir kennen uns alle mit diesem Crypto Zeug nicht aus.
Vielleicht kannst du noch ein paar Worte zu ihm sagen, warum ist er eine solche Autorität?
Das weiß ich gar nicht genau.
Aber warum ist er für dich eine solche Autorität?
Für mich, weil er zum Beispiel im This Week in Tech Podcast auch als so eine Instanz wahrgenommen wird. Und ich weiß, dass er mit seinen Publikationen zum Thema Millionen und Millionen verdient hatte, nachdem er sich die technische Reputation schon erarbeitet hat. Also er ist so eine Art Christian Drosten der Kryptowelt. Jetzt auch in einem Alter, wo man genug Geschichte aus den Anfängen der Computerspielerei und so weiter da hat. Also Bruce Schneier ist wirklich mal so. Also für mich und vielleicht auch für einige so der Typ, wo man dann einfach vertrauensvoll sagt, okay, wenn der der Meinung ist, dann ist das so. Und sie schreiben, wir sind 26 Computerwissenschaftler, Softwareingenieure und Technologen mit Erfahrung in Datenbanken, Open-Source-Prinzipien, Kryptographie und Finanzteknologie, denn die war ja schon immer sehr techniklastig. Und Zitat, und sie schreiben das an namentlich alle, Honorable, entweder den direkten Speaker, Majority Leader, House und Senat und auch alle relevanten Ausschussvorsitzenden. Also an sie ist es adressiert. Wir schreiben ihnen heute und fordern sie auf, den Behauptungen der Industrie, Krypto-Assets, manchmal auch Kryptowährungen, Kryptotoken oder Webm3 genannt.
Sehr gut, dass sie Assets schreiben, dass das präpariert ist.
Genau, sie erfassen mal alles. Also wir schreiben ihnen heute und fordern sie auf, den Behauptungen der Industrie, Krypto-Assets, seien eine innovative Technologie, die uneingeschränkt gut ist, kritisch und skeptisch gegenüberzustehen. Wir fordern sie auf, dem Druck der Finanziers, Lobbyisten und Förderer, im Originaltext Boosters, digitaler Vermögenswerte zu widerstehen, um einen sicheren Hafen für diese riskanten und fehlerhaften digitalen Finanzinstrumente zu schaffen und stattdessen einen Ansatz zu verfolgen, der das öffentliche Interesse schützt und sicherstellt, dass die Technologie wirklich im Dienste der Bedürfnisse der Bürger eingesetzt wird. Also das ist deutlich. Wir widersprechen nachdrücklich dem von denjenigen, die ein finanzielles Interesse an der Kryptoindustrie haben, verbreiteten Narrativ, dass diese Technologie eine positive Finanzinnovation darstellt und in irgendeiner Weise geeignet sind, die finanziellen Probleme zu lösen, mit denen normale Amerikaner konfrontiert sind. Also wir haben es hier mit einer Beerdigung aus ideologischer Richtung, mit allem, was mit Krypto irgendwas… Solange es um Assets geht. Also Währung ist ja schon falsch. Es sind ja im Grunde wirklich nur Assets. Dass wir dazu Geld sagen, obwohl wir es gar nicht als Geld verwenden, sondern wirklich nur als Geldspeicher bislang ist ja auch so ein Problem. Naja, nicht alles, was technisch funktioniert, sollte auch gemacht werden. Dieser Satz darf natürlich nicht fehlen. Blockchain-Technologie werde hier antiethisch eingesetzt. Und das liege schon an dem Basisdesign. Es ist ein Desaster für die Privatsphäre. Und für allgemeinen Zahlungsverkehr braucht man einen Human in the Loop. Man braucht irgendwen als Adresse, das ist übrigens das, was wir beim DSA gerade einbauen. Du musst irgendwen anrufen können, wenn irgendwas mit der Technik ist, die du benutzt. Das reicht nicht, es alles der Technik zu überlassen. Irgendwer betrügt mal irgendwen, irgendwer klickt mal falsch, es muss revidiert werden, zurück abgewickelt und so weiter. Wenn irgendwer einfach mal 5 Millionen überweist, dann kriegt man es nie zurück. Und der andere Seite freut sich dann einfach darüber, weil es technisch ausgeschlossen ist, das Geld zurückzugeben. Das ist keine Lösung. Blockchain ist eine Lösung für ein Problem, das sich bislang nicht fand. Das ist auch ein plakativer Satz, aber sehr gut, dass sie sich getraut haben, den nochmal in dieser Klarheit reinzuschreiben. Ja, es ist eine tolle Lösung und die können sich alle freuen, aber wir haben echt kein Problem dafür. Vor allem wir haben kein Problem, dass wir nicht mit existierenden Methoden schon besser machen. Es wäre eine Verschlechterung. Naja, die Probleme, die Bedrohung der nationalen Sicherheit, Finanzmarktinstabilitäten mit denen zu rechnen ist und natürlich Klimaschäden durch die Proof-of-Work-Technologie. Da ist ja Bitcoin ganz vorn dran, da gibt es Alternativen zu, aber naja. Und im Finale empfehlen wir dem Ausschuss über den Hype und das Getöse der Kryptoindustrie hinweg zu blicken oder hinaus zu blicken und nicht nur ihre inherenten Fehler und außergewöhnlichen Mängel zu verstehen, sondern auch die Litanei der technologischen Irrtümer, auf denen sie aufgebaut ist. Und dafür ist glaube ich der Bruce Schneier ganz wichtig, dass man nicht einfach sagt, naja, es ist ja eine coole Lösung, wir haben für sie nur kein Problem, sondern dass Bruce Schneier hier nochmal für uns zertifiziert mit antwortet, ne, es ist auch technologisch keine gute Lösung. Sie ist fehleranfällig, da sind Probleme, das sehen wir jetzt wieder bei den NFTs. Ja, super dezentral, müssen allerdings alle über einen Server verifiziert werden und dann klappt es doch nicht. Ja, oder man kauft sich, man kauft sich immer nur URLs, wenn die Server dahinter nicht laufen, kann man den Anspruch, den man mit dem NFT gerne darstellen möchte, nicht darstellen. Also man kann das auch alles ausknipsen, so wie man das Internet auch ausknipsen kann. Irgendwo sind immer Menschen in Verantwortung und haben dann entweder Macht oder, es passieren halt wirklich technische Fehler, nichts von diesen beiden, was eigentlich gelöst werden soll, an bisherigen Abwicklungsverfahren, wird dadurch gelöst, dass man jetzt auf diese Kryptoschiene geht. Also in deren Sicht, mal gucken, ob das da irgendwie gehört wird. In Amerika ist es natürlich auch wieder so ein offener Brief aus Verlegenheit. Und wir sehen ja, wie mächtig die Kryptolobby ist, wenn sie sich da schon Stadiennamen für 700 Millionen Euro in LA sichert, obwohl das Stadion vor zehn Jahren nur 350 Millionen Baukosten verursacht hat und so. Also da ist ja unglaublich viel Geld, um da so eine Art Politik jetzt durchzudrücken. Aber mal sehen, vielleicht liest ja jemand solche offenen Briefe da.
Schön wäre es, und schön wäre es, wenn er auch hier denn gelesen würde. Wir springen nochmal zurück zum Thema Habermas. Und zwar Slavoj Zizek ist sehr umtriebig und kritisiert auch, dass die Haltung Deutschlands, aber auch die Haltung des gesamten Westens zu zögerlich sei. Er hat ein Interview gegeben, Profil, dem österreichischen Medium, und sagt, die westliche Aparthei ist grenzenlos. Man muss die Linke davon überzeugen, sagte er in diesem Interview, dass die Unterstützung des ukrainischen Widerstands nicht automatisch bedeutet, den westlichen Imperialismus zu verteidigen. Ich glaube, hier ist ein Pappkamerad aufgestellt worden. Ja, es gibt noch so eine uralt anti-imperialistische Linke, wo man auch, glaube ich, nicht mehr viel Überzeugungsarbeit leisten kann. Aber wenn er jetzt von der allgemeinen Linken redet, dann, glaube ich, gibt es da wenig Kritik an der Unterstützung des ukrainischen Widerstands. Also er geht an diesem Interview auch darauf ein, dass Wagenknecht von ihr nichts interessantes kommen, nur bla bla. Da würde ich sagen, na ja, Wagenknecht ist aber auch wirklich nicht die Linke. Die hast du dir jetzt mal gerade da irgendwo ausgepickt, um dein Argument zu stützen. Und ja, das sei alles eine Tragödie und eine Katastrophe für die Linke. Und dann sagt er, die Linke ist bloß opportunistisch. Und dann wird er gefragt, ist der Pazifismus am Ende? Dann sagt er, die pazifistische Linke im Westen wird die große Verliererin sein. Sie wird ihre Glaubwürdigkeit einbüßen. Denn der Westen ist in seiner eigenen Melancholie gefangen, wir wissen, was wir eigentlich tun müssten, sehen aber, dass wir es nicht zu Wege bringen. Wenn wir uns nicht neu organisieren, sind wir verloren. Und da würde ich auch sagen, das kann man mal so sagen. Aber ich würde gerne auch hier wissen, was heißt das jetzt im konkreten Kriegsfall? Also eher ist es für eine Unterstützung der Ukraine. Aber wie weit soll die ausgelegt werden? Wir haben uns entschieden, nicht Kriegspartei zu sein. Und dann einfach zu sagen, das ist so eine Melancholie und wir müssen aus diesem Posteroischen da irgendwie rauskommen. Also ganz ähnlich wie Paul Mason. Dann muss ich dann gesagt bekommen, was soll das wirklich bedeuten? Ist das so, dass wir uns selbst bewaffnen müssen, dass wir reingehen müssen in einen Krieg? Dann muss das auch wirklich so ausgesprochen werden. Und dann kann man das ja selbst nochmal für sich durchdeklinieren, ob man das wirklich möchte. Und da würde ich auch dann bei Zizek sagen, das kann er nicht wollen. Und was ich hier bei Zizek kritisieren würde, ist etwas, was er selbst immer kritisiert hat. Nämlich, wenn linke Akademiker irgendwo noch eine Revolution in Lateinamerika am Horizont schimmern sehen, weil da irgendwelche wüste Straßenkämpfe oder so stattfinden. Und dann diese linken Akademiker, die fernab von diesen eigentlichen Konfliktfeldern sich dann groß solidarisieren in dem Wissen, dass sie selbst nie davon betroffen sind. Und bei Zizek habe ich hier auch den Eindruck, dass er glaubt, da das heroische Subjekt zu finden im ukrainischen Widerstand, das dann auch vielleicht politisierbar ist für alles Mögliche. Und das ist etwas, was dem Westen jetzt fehlt, weil wir eine postheroische Gesellschaft sind. Und dann würde ich sagen, aber was will er wirklich, dass wir wieder heroische Subjekte werden? Und wie sieht dann dieser heroische Kampf aus? Er hat dann in der Berliner Zeitung noch einen weiteren Text geschrieben, der auch im Guardian veröffentlicht wurde. Im Übrigen ganz interessant. Sijek hatte sich ja mit dem Guardian überworfen vor einigen Jahren. Jetzt ist er zurückgekehrt mit dieser Unterstützung für die Ukraine, mit dieser Anti-Habermas-Position. Und der Guardian ist ja momentan ganz auf Kurs. Wir müssen besonders viel Engagement zeigen. Also da ist ja auch dieses, naja, also das, was Catherine Liu schreibt, ist ja im Guardian auch sehr weit verbreitet, würde ich mal behaupten. Und er setzt sich dann da erst mal damit auseinander, dass wir uns nicht von Russland diktieren lassen sollen, wie wir uns zu verhalten haben. Wo ich sagen muss, naja, das Diktieren ist ja das eine. Wir müssen aber die Gefahr, doch uns, dieser Gefahr uns bewusst sein, wenn Russland mit dem Atomkrieg droht. Das heißt ja nicht gleich, dass man allem nachgibt. Das tun wir ja auch keineswegs. Also es wird ja die ganze Zeit versucht, dagegen etwas zu unternehmen in Form von Sanktionen, in Form von Waffenlieferungen. Es ist ja keineswegs eine Kapitulation des Westens. Und dennoch ist es ein kluges Abwägen, das nötig ist. Was diesen Text in der Berliner Zeitung aber ein bisschen interessanter macht, sind die Einlassungen zum Universalismus. Und zwar zentiert er da erstmal Medeev, der ehemalige Präsident Russlands, der sagt, dass die Welt auf den Zusammenbruch der Idee einer Amerika zentrierten Welt und das Entstehen neuer internationale Allianzen wartet, die auf pragmatische Kriterien beruhen. Was ist damit gemeint? Pragmatische Kriterien bedeutet die Missachtung allgemeiner Menschenrechte. Also das wird jetzt von Russland eingefordert. Wir brauchen eine Weltordnung, wo wir pragmatisch sind, was aber eigentlich bedeutet, Menschenrechte sind uns nicht so wichtig. Das ist so ein komisches Ding der liberalen Demokratien gewesen, damit haben wir nichts mehr zu tun. Und das ist etwas, wo Zizek sagt, da müssen wir höllisch aufpassen, wenn wir in genau diesen Zynismus von Russland hineinkommen. Er sagt, Europa verspricht nun der Ukraine zu helfen, das Getreide mit der Eisenbahn und mit Lastwagen zu transportieren, aber das ist eindeutig nicht genug, es ist ein weiterer Schritt nötig. Und dann sagt er jetzt eine klare Forderung, den Hafen für den Export von Getreide zu öffnen, einschließlich der Entsendung von Militärschiffen dorthin. Also er will schon, dass wir da uns wieder mehr engagieren und spricht dann über den Hunger in Afrika und Asien, wenngleich er hier auch nicht mal erwähnt, dass dieser Hunger auch schon viel länger da ist. Aber er versucht dann immer wieder zurückzukommen auf dieses Thema der Menschenrechte. Und er sagt dann, naja, es gibt auch ähnliche Ausdauerungen von Putin und von Lavrov. Und oftmals wird ja dann von Seiten Russlands argumentiert, der Westen hat Doppelstandards. Der Westen marschiert in den Irak ein. Der Westen hat auch gefoltert. Der hat Guantanamo und so weiter. Und jetzt wird uns aber was über Menschenrechte erzählt. Tschech sagt jetzt hier was sehr Richtiges. Er sagt, diese Äußerungen, die es da von Russland gibt, stimmen. Er sagt, ja, der liberale Westen ist heuchlerisch und wendet seine hohen Standards sehr selektiv an. Und jetzt kommt das große Aber, und das finde ich eigentlich das Bemerkenswert an diesem Text. Aber Heuchelei bedeutet, dass man gegen die Standards verstößt, die man verkündet und sich damit der immanenten Kritik aussetzt. Ich hatte das in unserer regulären Folge schon gesagt. Ja, wir haben diesen Irak-Krieg geführt, also Amerika den geführt, oder wir haben auch Afghanistan mitgemacht. Aber wir hatten die kritischen Filme zum Beispiel dazu. Und das ist nicht einfach nur so ein popkulturelles Phänomen. Und da sagt er, ja, Heuchelei bedeutet, dass man gegen die Standards verstößt, die man verkündet und sich damit einer immanenten Kritik aussetzt, wenn wir den liberalen Westen kritisieren, legen wir seine eigenen Standards zugrunde. Das heißt, wir haben nicht außerhalb Standards und sagen hier, das ist das falsche System, sondern aufgrund der Standards, die wir haben, können wir auch eine Selbstkritik leisten. Zum Beispiel auch im Falle Assange und müssen sagen, nein, der Mann muss frei, der gehört freigelassen. Was ist jetzt der Unterschied, wenn wir jetzt wirklich noch mal gucken, Universalismus-Menschenrechte zu Russland oder China? Was Russland anbietet, schreibt Zizek, ist eine Welt ohne Heuchelei, weil das Land keine globalen ethischen Standards setzt, sondern nur pragmatischen Respekt vor Unterschieden praktiziert. Die wollen ja eigentlich– und mit China haben wir das auch schon gehört– mit diesen anderen Menschenrechten oder unserer Art von Menschenrechten, die wollen eigentlich eine Identitätspolitik. Wir sehen das mit den Menschenrechten so, ihr seht das so, wir handhaben das so. Es kann alles nebeneinander hergehen. Aber der Universalismus der Menschenrechte kann nicht in irgendwelchen Variationen auftreten, sondern es gibt nur den Universalismus. Und in dem der Westen sich dessen auch bewusst ist, ist es auch richtig, dass er diese Selbstanklagen unternimmt, auch diese Selbstkritik zulässt, weil das uns unterscheidet von jenen, die eigentlich nur sagen, es gibt diese Doppelstandards. Also lasst uns doch einfach sagen, jeder hat so seine Standards und macht, wie er will. Schiedek bietet dann noch ein Beispiel. China akzeptiert das neue Afghanistan, während die Taliban ignorieren, was China mit den Uiguren macht. Das ist im Grunde die neue Globalisierung, die von Russland befürwortet wird. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu verteidigen, was in unserer liberalen Tradition erhalten ist, besteht darin, rücksichtslos auf ihre Universalität zu bestehen. Dem kann ich nur zustimmen und möchte aber hinzufügen, es wird uns jetzt über Jahrzehnte wahrscheinlich begleiten. Und es wird ganz schwierig sein, diese Universalität über unsere eigenen engen Grenzen der politischen Möglichkeiten hinaus zu verteidigen. Denn wir haben nicht diesen Paul Mason-Weg. Wir marschieren ein und befreien die Uiguren. Das ist nicht gegeben. Unsere Möglichkeiten sind die der Diplomatie, der wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen, auch der Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen. Und ich würde gerne, weil du nur noch zwei Texte hast, gleich springen noch zu Fukuyama, um da direkt anzuschließen. Denn Fukuyama hat ja einen Text veröffentlicht, in dem er sich fragt, ist das jetzt mit diesem Liberalismus eigentlich vorbei? Hab ich mich geirrt? Wie verhält es sich da eigentlich? Und Fukuyama macht hier nochmal was deutlich, was, glaube ich, auch wichtig ist. Denn er sagt, ja, natürlich ist das nicht einfach so eine große Fortschrittserzählung in der Geschichte. So kann man das nicht sehen. Und er zeigt dann nochmal, es gibt diesen Bogen der Geschichte, auf den Obama auch immer wieder zu sprechen kam in seinen Reden. Aber der verläuft natürlich mitunter mit vielen Brüchen. Die Frage stellt sich also, gibt es Geschichte im Sinne der Modernisierung? Und zweitens, wenn ja, auf welche Art von Gesellschaft weist sie hin? Das ist ja das, was Fukuyama immer interessiert hat. Gibt es so einen Fortschritt und führt er uns zu einer, ich sage einfach mal freieren Gesellschaft? Und er zeigt dann auf, wann der Staat aufkam als Konstrukt, wie es dann im 17. und 18. Jahrhundert in Westeuropa diese großen Umbrüche gab, wie das Recht plötzlich wichtig wird. Also der Wille des Herrschers steht nicht mehr im Vordergrund, sondern irgendwann ist es die Herrschaft des Rechts, die wir akzeptieren, die dann auch den Herrscher bestrafen kann, diese Herrschaft des Rechts. Und wir haben den technologischen Wandel, wir haben eine moderne Wirtschaftswelt. Und diese Ideen, schreibt er, waren Teil einer Doktrin, die unter dem Namen Liberalismus bekannt wurde und in der die politische Macht durch Gesetze und verfassungsmäßige Kontrollen der Autorität des Herrschers begrenzt wird. Das ist also diese moderne Erzählung, mit der sie beginnt. Eine Gruppe besitzt Kapital, eine andere arbeitet für sie und dazwischen entsteht eine Mittelschicht aus Fachleuten, Kaufleuten, Mittelsmännern und denjenigen, die Dienstleistungen für eine zunehmend komplexe Gesellschaft erbringen. Dann zeigt er, wie wir uns entwickeln von einer Gemeinschaft zu Gesellschaft. Bezieht sich hier nochmal auf Ferdinand Tönnies. Er sagt, es gibt also einen Bogen der Geschichte. Die zweite Frage ist, wohin führt er und insbesondere, ob er in Richtung Gerechtigkeit führt. Das ist interessant. Und in früheren historischen Epochen, schreibt Fukuyama, war der Bogen der Geschichte von der Gerechtigkeit weggezogen. Stammesgesellschaften sind relativ egalitär. Und dann kam aber mit dem modernen Staat durchaus Diktatur, Sklaverei oder denken wir auch an die Situation der Arbeiter im 19. Jahrhundert, auf die Engels als erstes hingewiesen hat. Was aber fragt Fukuyama, wenn der Bogen der Geschichte in eine andere Richtung zeigt? Vielleicht zu einem Hightech-Autoritarismus chinesischer Prägung oder zu einer nationalistischen, illiberalen Demokratie wie in Viktor Orbán's Ungarn. Da sagt er, das liberale Narrativ des historischen Fortschritts war eng mit dem Glauben verbunden, dass die Menschen rational sind und dass bessere Bildung und Zugang zu Informationen sie kritischer gegenüber ungerechten Autoritäten und offener für unterschiedliche Ideen machen würde. Dieses Szenario trifft auf das heutige China nicht zu, wo eine zunehmend gebildete Bevölkerung mit dem Leben in einer Diktatur zufrieden zu sein scheint. Also da sind ja nicht die Leute alle unglücklich. Genau, selbst in Russland sehen wir ja, der Widerstand ist gering und der ist vielleicht nicht nur gering, weil Russland oder weil die Regierung, weil Putin so repressiv ist.
Also man müsste sogar sagen, in China, selbst wenn die Leute unglücklich sind, suchen sie ihr Heil in der Partei mittlerweile. Also da wird ja die Ideologie sozusagen eng verklammert mit dem quasi Willen der Bevölkerung der Einzelnen.
Und dennoch glaubt Fukuyama an so einen Fortschritt, an eine Empathie. Er schildert dann eine Episode, die Tocqueville aufgezeichnet hat von Madame de Sévigné. Das war eine sehr gebildete aristokratische Metzenin in einem Pariser Salon des 17. Jahrhunderts. Sie schreibt einen heiteren Brief an ihre Tochter, in dem sie erzählt, dass sie Zeugin geworden ist, wie ein Schneider auf dem Rad zerschlagen wurde, weil er ein Leib Brot gestohlen hatte. Das ist eine amüsante Geschichte, weil dieser Schneider von ihr gar nicht als Mitmensch angesehen wird. Das ist irgendwas anderes, das hat mit mir nichts zu tun. Dieser Mangel an Empathie sei etwas, was die früheren Epochen geprägt hat. Und das würde aber nachlassen, wir werden empathischer. Wenngleich wir natürlich auch, würde ich dann hinzufügen, gute Tricks gefunden haben, dass wir zwar empathisch sind, in dem Sinne, dass wir da jetzt nicht mehr lachen würden, dass wir aber ganz gut outgesourct haben. Also wir sehen halt einfach nicht, was mit den Flüchtlingen passiert. Ich sehe nicht, wie da jemand ins Meer gedrängt wird oder so. Dadurch haben wir uns im Prinzip dieser Empathie dann auch entledigt. Aber er meint schon, für jede Generation wird es schwieriger, so zu sein. Und langfristig geht er davon aus, dass der Liberalismus zwar Höhen und Tiefen erlebt und erlebt hat, aber dass man doch immer wieder zu diesem Liberalismus zurückkommt. Und ein Beispiel, das er nennt, kann man glaube ich nicht von der Hand weisen. Er sagt, die liberale Idee bleibt für Menschen in aller Welt sehr lebendig. Und das wäre jetzt das, wo ich an Zizek anknüpfen möchte, weil er ja sagt, wir müssen diese Universalität verteilen. Und das ist quasi unser weiterer Ortsbonus, den wir haben. Nicht nur tolles BIP oder so, sondern der Ortsbonus ist auch diese liberale Demokratie. Und den Ortsbonus muss man aber auch dann auch anderen anbieten und nicht nur uns. Und wenn man diese Universalität hochhält, dann können wir auch da sehr selbstbewusst mit umgehen. Und das ist etwas, was Fukuyama hier schreibt und was nicht von der Hand zu weisen ist. Jedes Jahr verlassen Hunderttausende von Menschen, manchmal sogar Millionen arme, gewalttätige und schlecht regierte Länder auf der Suche nach einem besseren Leben. Das Ziel ihrer Wahl ist niemals China, Russland oder Venezuela. Vielmehr suchen sie nach gut regierten, liberalen Gesellschaften, in denen ihre Kinder mehr Freiheit und Chancen haben werden. Sie sind es, die viel mehr als die selbstgefälligen Bewohner liberaler Gesellschaften erkennen, dass es in der Tat einen Bogen der Geschichte gibt, an dessen Ende die Gerechtigkeit steht. Das ist die Schlusspointe dieses Textes. Und damit bin ich sehr froh, wie er das schreibt.
Das ist ja auch die große Schicksalsfrage des 21. Jahrhunderts. Denn im 20. Jahrhundert war es das Bevölkerungswachstum. Und im 21. Jahrhundert ist es die Bevölkerungsverteilung. Und interessanterweise wird die Freiheit ja immer nur dann geschätzt, wenn es ökonomisch auch gerade rund läuft. Ökonomisch läuft es aber nur rund, wenn über Migration, Wirtschaftsbevölkerungswachstum oder zumindest Stagnation da ist. Ansonsten, das sind dann die Schicksale Bulgarien, Ungarn und so weiter, der ganze Ostblock, wie man so schön sagt, wo Bevölkerungen schrumpfen und entsprechend dann auch die Wirtschaft in die Knie geht, da hat dann die Freiheit als Idee auch nicht mehr so den großen Stand. Und es werden dann auch nicht mehr, sind dann nicht mehr so die, wie nennt man sie, die Sehnsuchtsländer, in die man dann geht, sondern naja. Und das beste Beispiel dafür ist natürlich England, das jetzt einmal so richtig vor die Hunde geht und auch feststellt, was ausbleibende Migration bedeutet oder sogar zurückgehende Migration. Wenn da einfach wirklich die Menschen dann einfach abwandern, die vorher zugewandert sind. Und für Deutschland entscheidet sich es immer noch. Wir haben ja die Idee vorgeschlagen, jedes Land sucht sich, das ist von Stephen Miller die Idee, aber jedes Land sucht sich ein afrikanisches Partnerland und versucht dann da so eine Art Mentor inklusive Austauschprogramme und so weiter zu fahren. Naja, mal gucken. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Fukuyama werde ich natürlich auch noch lesen.
Genau, das war jetzt nur ein Artikel, den er veröffentlicht hat im Zuge des Krieges. Vielleicht widmen wir uns mal noch ganz seinem neuen Buch, das bald erscheinen wird.
Genau, bei Hoffmann und Kampe. Der Verlag hat mir jetzt auch den Katalog geschickt. Ich stehe tatsächlich, also man blättert so durch. Erstes Sachbuch Fukuyama blättert man um, dann komme ich schon.
Prima.
Fertig gefreut, dass ich da so an Fukuyama ranrücke gleich. Na ja, gut, bleiben wir mal bei diesen großen Fragen. Allerdings im Kleinen aufgehängt, nämlich was macht man jetzt mit der ganzen Kohle, die man hat mit dem ganzen Geld und die ESG-Investment-Strategien sind jetzt alle unter Druck geraten, schreibt Harriet Agnew in Financial Times. Dieser Text ist sehr empfehlenswert, auch noch mal selbst zu lesen, denn es ist ein sehr breites Wortspendespektrum, das man hier bekommt. Also in der Hinsicht eine schöne Telefonrecherchearbeit, wo die ganzen Stimmungs- und Gemütszustandslagen aus den beteiligten Büros, die Märkte, wie man so schön sagt, mal zusammengetragen wird. Also vor 10, vor 20 Jahren, vor zwei Jahrzehnten haben die UN in entsprechenden Kommissionen angefangen, ESG zu behandeln. Also das E steht für environmental, S für social und G für corporate, in Klammern, governance und daraus versucht mit den Millennium Goals und so weiter Investmentstrategien zu machen. Hören wir jetzt aus Europa-Field, Green Finance und so, da schlägt es sich nieder. Und bis 2018 spielte ESG in nur 1% der Earning-Calls eine Rolle, also wenn quartalsweise die Investoren angerufen werden. 2018 wissen wir, dann kam Greta, 2021 waren es schon 20%. Also da hat Greta für wirklich Bewegung gesorgt. Und die Investment-Strategien, die irgendwie ESG drin hatten im Label, ist jetzt hier so ein bisschen halbgehalb argumentiert, aber das ESG-Segment als Segment wuchs am schnellsten in den letzten Jahren, zum Beispiel im Jahresvergleich 2021 um 53% auf 2,7 Billionen Dollar Umfang. Und damit erst mal nur gemeint, dass so pseudomäßig neben investiert doch in Bildungstechnologie, Technologie für alte Menschen, Technologie für was weiß ich, Energie, dass dieses ESG-Segment, das dann natürlich so ein bisschen quer drüber liegt, selber als Magnet für Investmentgelder gut funktioniert hat bislang. Und jetzt kommt aber der Bruch. Die Menschen, die bisher dachten, ich habe so viel Geld, ich gehe mal in so ausgelabelte ESG-Anleihen, die entscheiden sich jetzt doch anders. Und wir haben auch immer noch eine unklare Lage. Was heißt ESG jetzt eigentlich? BlackRock als großer Geldeinsammler hat so seinen eigenen Standards. Die EU hat jetzt mit der Taxonomie versucht, so ein bisschen was zu machen. Und das MIT in Boston und die Uni Zürich haben sich das mal angeschaut. Wenn man sich die Kredit-Ratings der großen vier Agenturen anschaut, dann stimmen die zu 92% überein darin, wie sie Sachen bewerten. Also sie sind ziemlich deckungsgleich. Wenn man sich die bestehenden ESG-Ratings anguckt, auch von Agenturen oder Banken, die das machen, dann schwankt das so zwischen 38 und 71%. Das haben wir ja auch mitbekommen, wenn die EU-Kommission sich entscheidet. Ja, beim Thema Nachhaltigkeit spielt auch Atomkraftübergangsweise und auch das Öl noch eine Rolle. Dann passt das halt nicht sehr gut zu irgendwelchen überengagierten Banken, die dann sagen, nee, bei uns spielt das natürlich alles nicht eine Rolle. Und 38% Deckungskongruenz ist natürlich inhaltlich schon, naja, also da bedeutet ESG einfach alles. Und jetzt gab es ja am 31. Mai die Razzia bei DWS, also hier Deutsche Bank und DWS. Das ist hier auch ein bisschen ein Aufhänger im Text, hat also weltweit für Aufsehen gesorgt. Es gab eine Whistleblowerin der Serie Fixler, interessanter Name für eine Whistleblowerin, also die wollte das mal fixen und hat es dann entsprechend an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht. Und sie sagt ja, dass es da jetzt zu dieser Razzia kam, ist ja nun wirklich ein Wake-up-Call, denn das bedeutet wieder Diesel-Skandal so ein bisschen in Amerika. Man kann nicht alles auf seine Werbeprochüre schreiben, sondern es muss dann auch mal den Sachen entsprechend, ja also Greenwashing einfach so geht dann nicht. Und leider wurde aber mittlerweile das ESG-Label von den Bürokraten und Marketeers gekapert. Es ist eigentlich nichts mehr wert, sagt die Fixler. Und dann stimmen da relativ viele, die sich damit auskennen und die damit hantieren überein. Und dann ist im Text so eine kleine Zäsur, und das ist wirklich interessant, denn der Ukraine-Krieg passierte und wir wissen, welche Investitionen seitdem besonders lokativ waren. Der Energiesektor verdient sich dumm und dähnlich. Die kriegt sogar nach gerade Tankrabatt-Subventionen hinterhergeschüttet, obwohl die schon so hohe Preise haben, die nun nicht gedeckt sind durch irgendwas. Und der Rüstungssektor, also dass sich die ganzen europäischen, amerikanischen Rüstungskonzerne mindestens verdoppeln, bringt alles ein bisschen in Verlegenheit, weil diese Sachen haben alle kein ESG-Label drauf. Also weder der Rüstungssektor noch der Energiesektor.
Es gab ja tatsächlich Vorschläge dahingehend, dass die auch noch unter ESG gelabelt werden. Und das ist ja dann maximal lächerlich.
Ja, genau. Und das sagt hier auch Ian Simm, der Gründer von Impex Asset Management. Und die wollten einen Impact machen und haben damals so ESG-Pionier-mäßig und dann eben auch der Welle mitgeschwommen. Inzwischen verwalten die 37 Milliarden Dollar. Es ist superschwer und wird immer schwerer, die finanziellen Werte, also Risiko in Rendite, und die ethischen Werte, also ESG, unter einen Hut zu bringen. Die schwedische SEB-Bank, auch eine der Pioniere, hat zum Beispiel Rüstung ganz früh ausgeschlossen. Und jetzt haben wir aber einen Krieg und sehen, dass wir uns irgendwie verteidigen müssen und finden es total gut, Waffen sogar zu verschenken und so weiter. Nur, wo kommen denn diese Waffen her? Die müssen ja irgendwie hergestellt werden. Und nun überdenkt die SEB-Bank diese Opposition derzeit, und Artis Papriks, der lettische Finanzminister, wird hier nochmal zitiert, der hat nämlich die SEB-Bank direkt kritisiert. Und ich bin verärgert, wie sollen wir unser Land so entwickeln? Ist nationale Sicherheit keine ethische Angelegenheit? Und das ist natürlich irgendwie eine absolut valide Frage dieser Zeit. Also kann man den aus Grund ethischer Bedenken, es schwerer machen, Verteidigungstechnik zu kaufen, um sich dann im Zweifel und so weiter, wir wissen ja, die ganze Russland-Diskussion.
Nur zugleich wissen wir ja, dass wir mit diesen Waffen ja auch nicht weiterkommen. Also das ist für mich immer diese Absurdität jetzt auch, dass gesagt wird, wir rüsten jetzt gerade diese 100, wir machen diese 100 Milliarden frei für die Ukraine. Also das sind ja nicht 100 Milliarden, die an die Ukraine gehen, sondern da wird ja jetzt irgendwelches Kriegsgerät für angeschafft und für einen Krieg, in den wir aber nicht eintreten können, weil wir diese nukleare Bedrohung haben. Und das ist das Absurd. Also ich würde dafür sagen, hier wird ein Industrie-Sektor sehr reich gemacht, ein dumpfes Gefühl in der Bevölkerung wird mit abgeholt und man kann relativ populistische Politik damit betreiben.
Ist ja beim Energiesektor genauso. Es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Grund für diese hohen Ölbenzinpreise. Denn das Öl ist ja nur aufgrund von Erwartungen so teuer. Es wird ja gerade wenig Öl gefördert oder so. Und man sieht ja auch an den Tankstellen, dass jetzt Tankwatt Probleme haben, weil sie immer noch das teurere Öl verkaufen, das sie vor vier Wochen gekauft haben. Bei vielen Konkurrenten greift aber jetzt schon der Tankwatt bei ihnen noch nicht. Also müssen sie das von vorher teuer gekaufte Öl jetzt billiger verkaufen und finden dafür aber wenig Kunden, weil die Konkurrenz ist ja trotzdem da. Klar, es wird gebraucht. Am Ende sind also die Kunden gerade knapp und nicht die Produkte. Und das muss man erstmal in einer ordentlichen Ökonomie auf die Reihe bekommen. Und man beginnt am besten damit, indem man ein bisschen aufräumt. Also Ian Sim spricht sich auch dafür aus als ESG-Pionier. Wir müssen das Label jetzt mal, wir brauchen irgendwas Neues. Wir können jetzt in so Kriegszeiten und so weiter diese Verlegenheit, in der die SEB-Bank in Schweden da gebracht wird, nicht einfach mit uns führen. Einen kurzen Prozess machen einfach Blackrock und Vanguard. Ich zitiere mal direkt aus dem Text. Vanguard erklärt, es habe sich geweigert, neue Investitionen in fossile Brennstoffe zu stoppen und seine Unterstützung für die Förderung von Kohle, Öl und Gas einzustellen. Blackrock kündigte unterdessen an, dass es wahrscheinlich gegen die meisten Aktionärsanträge stimmen werde, die von Klimalobbyisten eingebracht wurden und ein Verbot neuer Öl- und Gasförderung zum Ziel haben. Also Blackrock wird seine Macht nicht dafür benutzen, jetzt irgendwelche Kickifucks-Sachen, wie es wahrscheinlich gelabelt wird demnächst. Also so klingt dann das ESG-Label aus. Sachen mitzustimmen, wenn die Länder gerade darauf aus sind, sich Energie unabhängig zu machen, sei es auch auf Kosten des Klimawandels. Larry Fink wird also hier eine dramatische Wende unterstellt und das können wir bezeugen, denn wir haben ja seine Briefe an die Aktionäre jetzt auch schon zwei Jahre lang gelesen.
Aber sollte man da nicht jetzt einfach auch, zumindest hier im Salon, mal rein Wein einschenken und sagen, es war an sich eine schöne Idee mit dem Klimawandel, da mal was gegen zu tun. Aber jetzt machen wir halt irgendwas anderes weiter. Und wie gesagt, wer Geld hat, kann sich eine Klimaanlage leisten. Und sonst schon mal drüber nachdenken, was man sonst noch tun könnte. Und das Leben genießen. Und ruhig auch mal lieber die U-Bahn stehen lassen und das Auto nehmen, weil es bequemer ist. Das hat ja eh keinen Zweck.
Du, ich will ja ein bisschen diesen Fadlisten machen. Wir haben ja diesen Larry Fink Brief von 2020 damals gelesen. Und da stand ja drin, und wir wissen ja, die wollen ja einfach, dass Märkte noch da sind. Egal mit welchen Playern darauf, da sie eh in allen Playern investiert sind. Und dieser Schutz der Märkte bedeutet, dass man auf Kredite für Häuser, die in Nähe von Küsten stehen, sich nochmal genau anschaut, ob man die wirklich finanziert. Weil die Küstenstreifen wandern ja zurück und am Ende ist nach 30 Jahren das Haus nichts wert. Und davon, also das bringt ja niemanden was. Also braucht man, um die Märkte selbst zu schützen, doch so eine Hinwendung zum Klima. Und jetzt haben wir durch den Ukraine-Krieg aber so ganz particuläre Interessen, wie zum Beispiel, und das zeigte sich ja in der Taxonomie, die ja zum Glück noch ein bisschen vor dem Ukraine-Krieg verabschiedet wurde. Sonst wäre dir natürlich auch ein Tisch gefallen. Dass man jetzt in Deutschland zum Beispiel sagt, naja, wir brauchen Brückentechnologien, aber langfristig brauchen wir den Europäischen Windpark in der Nordsee. Also eröffnet man jetzt den ersten und plant die nächsten 30 Gigawatt, und dann weiß man, so in 20 Jahren ist das irgendwie fertig. Bis dahin macht man noch das mit der Kohle, aber nur weil die Kohle-Löcher eh schon offen sind oder weil die Gasleitungen schon liegen. Aber man sieht eigentlich schon, ab wann sich es nicht mehr rechnet, nämlich relativ früh. Man kommt einfach gegen Windkraft und Solarenergie nicht an, preislich. Nur weil man schon drin investiert ist, bleibt man noch und dann halt einfach ein bisschen länger. Und in deren Sicht hat der Text hier auch einen interessanten Ausklang. Zum einen Stuart Kirk, das war der HSBC-Investment Chief, der den Spruch sagte, Klimawandel ist kein finanzielles Risiko für Investoren. Und dafür wurde aber auch gefeuert. Also die Stimmung ist doch noch irgendwie da und sei es nur so an der Oberfläche. Und Karsten Stendelwatt, das ist Bridgewater Associates, also alles diese Unternehmen, die werden auch ein bisschen vorgestellt im Text, der nochmal diese kleine Parenthese jetzt gerade betont. Jetzt gerade ist Ukraine Aufregung, weshalb man jetzt gerade den Ländern nicht absprechen kann, irgendwie händeringend nach Unabhängigkeit zu suchen und sei es über den Klima, also klimaschädliche Technologien, aber im Großen und Ganzen schon allein über den Preis und so weiter und so fort. Der Text macht dann vor seinem Finale noch mal diesen kleinen globalen Umschwenk. Wenn wir jetzt so ein EGSG-Stress hatten, der ja auch mit so Awareness und ein bisschen Wokeness auch drin hat und so, Fridays for Future, Alarmismus, was bedeutet es eigentlich, wenn wir ganze Länder ausschließen? Denn so wie wir bei der Ukraine gerade sagen, naja, die Länder nehmen sich schon wieder Öl, um sich in Sicherheit zu bringen, aber nicht Russisches. Also das ist ja auch gerade ganz stark, dass wir uns eben von Russland los sagen wollen. Also der Text fragt sich hier so ein bisschen, übertreiben wir es ein bisschen und wie ist dann erst der Umgang mit China? Wenn wir bei Russland jetzt schon sagen, also die nehmen wir jetzt mal völlig raus, da ist uns auch der Preis egal, wir wollen raus aus russischem Öl. Was bedeutet es eigentlich für China? Der Text geht aber nicht näher drauf ein. Ich würde sagen, das ist so eine Aufgabenstellung, die die Financial Times dann als nächstes mal aufarbeitet. Wie man mit diesen großen ethischen Fragen, das ist ja eben auch schon angedeutet, bei G-Jack und Mason und so spielt das ja überall eine Rolle. Wie gehen wir mit diesen ideologischen Konflikten mit China da um? Können wir sie einfach komplett wegboykottieren oder brauchen wir ein politisches Programm, das uns beides ermöglicht? Die Ablehnung, der grundsätzlichen Ideologie, aber trotzdem auch die Hinwendung, so ein paar Synergieeffekte im Handel oder wie auch immer zu nutzen. Und das ist nun hier beim Klimathema natürlich besonders knifflig, denn dieses ESG-Thema wird hier erst mal beerdigt. Die Großbritannien wollte jetzt ein eigenes Label machen, die EU wollte Green Finance machen mit der Zentralbank zusammen. Das sind nun Sachen, die liegen erst mal so auf Halde. Die BaFin hat ihr eigenes Klassifizierungsprogramm schon explizit gestoppt. Marc Branson, der BaFin-Präsident, meinte, dafür haben wir, also für permanente Regulierung ist gerade nicht die richtige Lage. Wir werden jetzt erst mal Kriegsende und so weiter abwarten.
Aber das bleibt ja bei dem systemischen Konflikt. Sie werden ja auch immer wieder neue Ausreden finden, warum wir noch mehr für die Rüstung ausgeben. Also selbst wenn morgen Frieden in der Ukraine wäre und die Ukraine alle Landstriche bekommen würde, die sie einfordert, jetzt diese Lenske benennt, selbst dann, also ich glaube, dass man da jetzt so ein Jahrzehnt der Aufrüstung, in dem wir nun zwar in allen Ländern, es gibt ja kein Land, das zurückrüstet, das abbaut. Und ich, also deswegen finde ich es so fatal, weil man noch mal jetzt auf so einer individuellen Art ja immer Leuten irgendwas noch mal dektieren will, wie sie leben und handeln sollen. Also wie gesagt, also ich kann jeden, um das mal so dezent zu formulieren, jeden gut verstehen, der macht, was er will.
Aber wir erinnern uns, Ursula von der Leyen hat ja die Green Finance und Taxonomiesachen nie unter diesem, das ist für den Klimawandel, sondern das war immer nur so Kulisse. Ihr eigentliches Argument ja war ja, das ist die neue Wachstumsstrategie für Europa. Also ein ganz klares wirtschaftliches Ansinn. Beispielsweise, indem man sagt, wir können der saarländischen Stahlindustrie im Grunde nur helfen, indem wir einen großen Zaun um Europa bauen und sagen, wenn die Chinesen uns da Stahl liefern, legen wir einen großen Zoll drauf und den können wir nur rechtfertigen, indem wir sagen, der Stahl unterscheidet sich von unserem, der ist nämlich nicht grün hergestellt worden. Und dann ist das das Signal für die im Saarland, wenn ihr es schafft, euren Hochofen auf Wasserstoff umzubauen, und der ist vielleicht sogar grüner Wasserstoff, dann habt ihr hier nicht nur einen Wettbewerbsvorteil gegen China, sondern dann steht euch der 500 Millionen Markt Europa, also 500 Millionen Einwohner Markt Europa zur Verfügung und anderen eben nicht, dafür sorgen wir dann. Und sie zitieren hier Zeika Nusaybe, der Geschäftsführer von Federated Hermes, was auch immer die Unternehmen wie gesagt, kann man nachgugeln und der sagt, wir dürfen Ethik und ESG nicht verwechseln, denn das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge. Und das war, so wie ich das sehe, in diesen ganzen europäischen Anstrengungen schon so angelegt, dass man sich eben nicht allzu sehr von so einer ethischen Überlegung treiben lässt, sondern von, wo sind die potenzielle Wachstumsstrategien zu generieren, also politische Rahmenbedingungen so zu ändern, dass man wieder Anreize schafft, Unternehmen zu führen, zu gründen, wie auch immer, rentite Erwartungen auszubeprägen. Und der einzige Weg ist in diese grüne Richtung. Das ist das einzige, wo man argumentieren kann, dass man das machen muss. Und das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so schwer, wenn man dann als politische Handlungsempfehlung einfach sagt, naja, um für solche ökonomische Umweltbedingungen zu sorgen, fängt man halt mal an, die ganze Verschmutzung einfach einzupreisen. Preisschild dran, zack, hat man einen Benchmark. Und schon hat man ein politisches Programm, beispielsweise dieser Grenzanpassungsmechanismus oder was auch immer. Und so kann man eben auch, das sind immer diese großen Herangehensweisen, man will, dass die Leute gesünder essen. Na dann kann man natürlich in irgendwelchen Zeitungen, irgendwelche individuellen Texte, und dann geht jemand einkaufen und kauft sich das und das. Oder man macht es über die Kantine. Und diese Shifts werden ja so langsam beobachtet, dass die Currywurst so langsam abgelöst wird und man auch in der Schule zum gesünderen Essen und da so eine Gewöhnung und dann fordert man das auch für den Alltag und lernt so ein bisschen darüber. Und das ist natürlich politisch möglich. Man muss halt nur eine Politik dazu machen. Also wenn Europa jetzt fünf neue Pflöcke einschlägt und das als Benchmark für ein Unternehmen dann auch zählt und militärisch, wichtig vielleicht auch, wie die Zukunft militärisch durchgesetzt wird, dass so ein Stahl dann wirklich nicht hier irgendwie reingeschleust wird, der im Hochofen auf Kohlebasis in Indien hergestellt wurde, dann sind hier auch, würde ich sagen, also dann kann man das vielleicht auch als nächsten Schritt sehen, dass man jetzt dieses ESG-Theater, und es sind eben langwierige Prozesse, jetzt einmal gemacht hat 20 Jahre und die nächsten 20 Jahre geht man das mal nicht nur über diese ethische, moralische Schiene an, sondern auch über dieses ganz explizite von der EU-Kommission vorgestellte Wachstumsstrategie-Projekt und dann ist man ja wirklich im Gleichklang mit Blackrock und so weiter. Also ich würde sagen, das ist hoffnungsstiftend.
Ich glaube, nein, also ich glaube, dass gerade hier noch mal die großen Investoren, die institutionellen Anleger versuchen, da mit Reibach zu machen, womit man auch in den vergangenen Jahren am besten Reibach machen konnte.
Aber es werden ja keine neuen Kohlelöcher eröffnet oder so.
Na ja, in Europa vielleicht nicht, aber warten wir ab. Oder auch die Rüstungsindustrie boomt. Ich habe es im Kino gesehen, Werbung für Rheinmetall suchen Azubis. Also wie gesagt, ich reagiere inzwischen schon fast allergisch, wenn mir noch irgendwas zum Thema Klimawandel gesagt wird. Aber ich sage, bitte lass mich damit jetzt in Ruhe. Nimm deine 100 Milliarden und wirf sie auf irgendeinen Rüstungskonzern. Aber ich fahre jetzt gleich mal mit dem Auto irgendwo hin. Also ich bin und kann es nur jedem sehr empfehlen, also heute wirklich Thema Lebenshilfe. Man lebt doch ein bisschen befreiter dann wieder, weil man. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Man ist also ich bin jetzt ich bin so enttäuscht. Ich bin so enttäuscht auch. Also ich habe mir natürlich nie was von den Grünen erhofft. Aber dass das wirklich da geschlossen diese Hupfdohlen alle für Aufrüstung so stimmen und dieser ganze Diskurs nur in diese Richtung geht und dann auch noch eine Mehrheit dafür da ist, dass man hier Atombomben stationiert und so. Da muss ich sagen, dann können wir das so gerne so machen. Aber dann lasst mich bitte mit diesem anderen Kram in Ruhe. Also wir können nicht beiseite. Ich kann nicht sagen, ja Atomwaffen, aber ich lasse das Auto mal stehen. Also das geht nicht. Also da muss ich sagen, nee, dann machen wir gerne beides. Aber dann möchte ich auch weiter meinen Lebensstil pflegen, der nicht klimafreundlich ist. Aber ich kann aber beides zusammen, das ist so eine kognitive Dissonanz in mir. Das ist mir dann zu wahnsinnig. Und deswegen glaube ich, wird sich das auch, also ich glaube, was ich jetzt hier gerade artikuliere, ist ja eine polemische Zuspitzung einer längeren gedanklichen Auseinandersetzung. Ich glaube ja, dass sich genau dahin die Gesellschaft bewegen wird, dass ein Großteil einfach sagen wird, ja gut, wenn es noch um die eigene Gesundheit geht, wird man sich vielleicht ein bisschen anders ernähren. Aber sonst wird man einfach sagen, gut, das war jetzt so ein Ding, aber jetzt macht jeder, wie er will, wie er will. Also ich glaube, das gibt es in der großen Bevölkerungsmehrheit, ist das wieder ganz stark da. Und dann gibt es noch irgendwie so Feinde nach außen, gegen die kann man sich dann aufrüsten und ausrüsten. Aber ich glaube, dass wir uns da eher von, also ich glaube, dass der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel als effektiver Kampf in sehr weite Ferne gerückt ist und genauso wie es keine Mobilitätswende geben wird. Also nichts deutet darauf hin, ich habe ja wieder nur Katastrophen erlebt, nichts deutet darauf hin, dass sich das da anders entwickeln wird. Also ich glaube, das bleibt leider, wird das eine ganz individuelle Geschichte werden, wer für den Klimawandel gerüstet sind. Das sind diejenigen, die ihre Häuser ganz gut irgendwo isoliert haben und irgendwo sicher wohnen oder so was. Aber das wird gesamtgesellschaftlich eher ein Debakel sein. Also da kann ich jetzt nicht mit Optimismus glänzen.
Also ich glaube, niemand ist für den Klimawandel gerüstet. Es geht ja nicht nur um die Temperaturen, die man selbst erlebt, wo eine Klimaanlage hilft, sondern auch alle Versorgungsfragen. Na mal sehen, die Deutsche Bahn hat ja eine große Revision oder Begutachtung ihrer ganzen Gleisanlagen eingekündigt für 2025 oder so.
Toll.
Soll sich schon mal auf Verspätungen durch Baumaßnahmen einstellen. Ja, also das wird ganz Deutschland, wird in Stuttgart 21 verwandelt, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, das wird, also es ist ja jetzt schon eine Katastrophe. Ich kann auch inzwischen jeden verstehen, der sagt, ich kaufe mir einen Helikopter und fliege nur noch durch die Gegend. Also ich kann das absolut nachvollziehen, weil es ist eine Katastrophe. Es hat mir so viel Zeit und Kraft schon geraubt. Nein, leider, das ist leider ein Einsatz meiner finanziellen Möglichkeiten. Aber das ist genau die Richtung, in die das gehen wird. Es wird dann Mobilität für einige wenige geben und der Rest bleibt halt immobil. Und das ist, das ist so unendlich traurig. Und dass da auch tatsächlich keine politischen Forderungen draus erwachsen, sondern man, das ist ja auch diese interessante Dissonanz, die man erleben kann. Die bewilligen 100 Milliarden und tun dann so, aber es sei sonst überall wieder doch knapp. Also das ist, hast du nicht diese enorm fatalistische Stimmung? Wenn du siehst, da wird mal ganz schnell was auf den Weg gebracht. Und dann in diesen entscheidenden kleinen Schritten, wo es nur mal um so was Läppisches wie die Bahn geht, tut sich so gut wie nichts. Und du musst dir dann noch von irgendwelchen SPD, Social Media-Clowns anhören. Nee, wir tun ja auch schon bald was. Wir haben da irgendwie paar hundert Millionen für irgendeine Digitalisierung ausgegeben. Also sowas hört man auch bei Twitter. Also es ist einfach, ja, also ich würde sagen, da sollte man doch wieder sich auf den privaten Rahmen konzentrieren und sich eine schöne Zeit machen.
Also ja, ich widerspreche nicht, klar muss man sich privat eine schöne Zeit machen, auch wenn es gut läuft.
Das muss ja schöne Zeit, muss ja nicht heißen, dass man jetzt wie die Axt im Walde lebt. Das soll ja nicht das Ziel sein, aber ich finde doch diese Ambitionen, die da mitunter genannt werden, so jetzt aber jetzt noch mal hier richtig jetzt packen wir es an, den traue ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz. Da will ich mich eher vor zurückhalten. Da fehlt mir der Idealismus, dafür bin ich dann, vielleicht ist das dann eine Generation von, dafür kann ich zumindest sagen, bin ich jetzt zu alt. Also das habe ich jetzt ein paar Jahre mal so alles durchgespielt und dann ist es auch gut.
Also ich halte es mit George Soros. Wir müssen jetzt mal diesen Ukraine-Krieg beenden, damit wir uns das Klima kümmern können.
Und dann kommt das nächste, warum wir es wieder gerade nicht machen können. Wir werden sehen. After the Titan-Wende, Jürgen Habermas and Germany's New Identity Crisis von Adam Tooze. Der schildert nochmal ganz genau, woher kommt Habermas, was war die SPD unter Willy Brandt, wer hat das fortgesetzt, Schröder, Merkel, all das. Kann man sehr gut nachlesen in dem Text, vieles kennen wir. Es richtet sich an ein englischsprachiges Publikum, New Statement erschienen. Was uns aber interessiert ist, was Adam Tooze jetzt generell zu Habermas zu sagen hat. Er weist auch daraufhin, das ist auch nicht nur eine deutsche Geschichte, sondern er sagt, Öl ist ein weitaus größeres Geschäft, als das russische Gas, von dem Deutschland abhängig ist. Und es waren britische, amerikanische und französische Ölkonzerne, die 1990er und 2000er Jahre große Investitionen in Russland tätigten. In der Diplomatie bemüht sich die guistische, guilistische Tradition in Frankreich ebenfalls um ein Gleichgewicht zwischen Washington und Moskau. In Italien ist die Sympathie für Russland tief verwurzelt. Und dann ist da noch Londongrad, also da sind ja dann auch die russischen Oligarchen. Es wäre törig zu behaupten, dass die Ostpolitik in Deutschland erst jetzt mit Putins Einmarsch der Ukraine umstritten ist. Sie waren nicht einfach so hegemonial, sagt er. Und Habermas, den zeigt er dann als jemand, der aus der Frankfurter Schule kommt, dann aber den Marxismus hinter sich lässt. Sein Leben lang, schreibt Tooze, ist er damit beschäftigt mit der Möglichkeit von Vernunft und Emanzipation, die der Sprache, dem Diskurs und der Deliberation innewohnt, zu schauen, wie kann man damit eine andere Politik gestalten, eine andere Gesellschaft. Er hat sich ja dann gegen Derrida gewandt, hat aber dann auch 1990 die Bombardierung des Kosovo durch die NATO unterstützt. Und manche haben auch gesagt, Habermas ist eigentlich so ein Apologet der westlichen Macht. Übrigens hat Zizek das auch immer wieder betont. Aber daraus zu schließen, dass Habermas eine konformistische Figur ist, bedeutet seine Philosophie, seine Politik, aber vor allem seine öffentliche Rolle im modernen Deutschland gründlich misszuverstehen, sagt er. Habermas hat sich mit Derridadan wiederum, mit dem er einst verfeindet war, gegen den Irak-Krieg gewandt. Er hat aber auch angeprangert, dass die EU immer technokratischer wird. Er ist kein Pazifist, schreibt Tooze. Habermas ist kein Pazifist. Die Ablehnung von Gewalt hat ihre Grenzen dort, wo Grundfreiheiten auf dem Spiel stehen. Habermas räumt ein, dass Waffentieferungen an die Ukraine unerlässlich sind. Was er beanstandet, sind nicht die Forderung nach mehr, sondern die Art und Weise, wie sie erhoben werden. Was ihn beunruhigt, ist die Zitat, Selbstsicherheit mit der die moralisch entrüsteten Ankläger in Deutschland auf eine beschauliche und zurückhaltende Bundesregierung losgehen. Und diese Selbstsicherheit, sagen auch du, verrät sich selbst jeder vernünftig denkende Mensch, ist sich darüber im Klaren, dass Putins Aggression kein Erfolg beschieden sein darf. Aber wir sollten uns auch einig sein, dass ein Krieg mit Russland undenkbar ist. Russland ist eine Atommacht und eine Eskalation ist ein entsetzliches Risiko. Jede vernünftige politische Intervention, so Habermas, muss sich diesem Dilemma stellen. Tooze betont dann diejenigen, die argumentieren, die Berücksichtigung der nuklearen Betrohung durch Russland bedeutet, sich erpressen zu lassen, haben Recht. Ihr Fehler besteht jedoch darin, sich einzubilden, dass sie mit dem Hinweis auf diese Tatsache das Argument irgendwie beendet haben. In Wirklichkeit haben sie das Problem nur neu formuliert. Also, man kann sagen, ja, der erpresst uns. Aber das Problem ist leider dann nicht verschwunden. Dann hat man es nur neu formuliert, sagt Tooze. Ein Teil der Spannung entsteht in Deutschland selbst. Also Kritiker haben ja eingeräumt, dass Habermas da mit dieser Generation, mit diesem Generationen-Konflikt auch arbeitet. Also die Jungen, die Alten, wer meint, was jetzt gerade zum Krieg. Und was nochmal ganz interessant ist, ist, wie Kritiker behauptet haben und Habermas bereitwillig einräumt, sind er und seine Generation unauslöschlich von der Politik des Atomzeitalters und seiner Folgen geprägt. Das diktierte ein Ende der Militärgeschichte im herkömmlichen Sinne. Ihre Kinder und Enkel haben eine Kultur geerbt, die, wenn überhaupt, noch mehr von der Kraft des internationalen Rechts überzeugt ist. Und nach Habermas Lesart ist es genau diese normative Verpflichtung, die sie dazu bringt, zu fordern, dass Putin vor den Hach gebracht wird. Unpassenderweise ist es ausgerechnet Habermas, der sie daran erinnern muss, dass weder Russland noch die Vereinigten Staaten die Autoritäten des Internationalen Gerichtshofs anerkennen und dass die Forderung, Putin als Kriegsverbrecher vor Gericht zu stellen, einer Kriegserklärung gleichkäme. Wenn ehemalige Pazifisten nun die Verteidigung der Ukraine zu einem Kreuzzug für einen gerechten Krieg machen, ist das, wie Habermas es ausdrückt, weniger eine Hinwendung zum Realismus, als vielmehr eine Umkehrung des Realismus. Der gemeinsame Nenner ist ein leidenschaftliches Bekenntnis zu normativen Standards angesichts harter Realitäten. Habermas zielt hier ab auf diese Gleichzeitigkeiten. Also wir haben diese verschiedenen Diskurse, die gleichzeitig sind. Wir haben aber auch Ungleichzeitigkeiten bei der Staatenbildung. Und das ist nochmal ein Punkt, den ich ganz kurz ansprechen will von Tooze, dass er auf Folgendes eingeht. Er sagt, die Ukraine befindet sich in der Phase der Nationalstaatsbildung. Deutschland ist weit darüber hinaus. Bei einer Überprüfung ihrer spontanen Reaktionen der Begeisterung und Solidarität mit der Ukraine täten die Deutschen und wir anderen im Westen gut, diese Kluft und ihre Folgen zu bedenken. Wir freuen uns über das Heldentum der Ukrainer, das den enttäuschten Zustand unserer eigenen Politik in ein kreles Licht rückt. Aber unsere postheroische Kultur kann nicht einfach mit Abscheu abgetan werden. Es ist eine logische historische Folge des Naturschirms, unter dem wir weiterhin leben. Also wir können da mal kurz begeistert sein, aber wir leben unter diesem Naturschirm. Und aus diesem heraus sprechen wir in dieser Weise. Und ja, die Ukraine bildet sich als Nation. Deutschland und auch andere Länder sind da weit rüber. Und diese Distanz zwischen den etablierten Nationalstaaten und dem künftigen Nationalstaat hat auch Folgen für beide Seiten. Tooze schreibt, wir sollten nicht von der sicheren Tribüne aus nach mehr Blut jubeln. Aber auch die Ukraine muss ihre diplomatische Taktik über Denken fordert. Er und wovor Habermas dann die Landsleute warnt, ist die Illusion, dass es über die Ukraine einen Weg zurück in die Zukunft gibt. So schreibt das Tooze. Das ist sehr schön. Er schreibt das besser als Habermas eigentlich. Die postheroische Haltung ist eine historisch angemessene Reaktion auf die Geschichte Europas seit dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges und des Kalten Krieges. Der Versuch, die emotionale und kulturelle Kluft zur Ukraine angesichts der anhaltenden Realität des nuklearen Pads zu schließen, ist sowohl unrealistisch als auch gefährlich. Und deswegen sieht auch Tooze in Macrons Wiederwahl ein neues Fenster der Möglichkeiten. Und auch er fragt sich, wird Europa diese Möglichkeiten ergreifen?
Sehr gut, wie immer, ist einfach ein Spektakel. Ich mach's kurz, denn der Text ist auch kurz. Thomas Piketty, der schreibt ja ansonsten immer mega lange Bücher. In dem Fall ist es ein LeMond-Text, der die Tage publiziert wurde und von Steffen Vogel für Die Blätter übersetzt wurde in der aktuellen, also gestern erschienenen Ausgabe. Linker Aufbruch in Frankreich. Wir können uns das hier auch, also es wurde zurecht auf Deutsch übersetzt. Am 12. und 19. Juni sind also Parlamentswahlen in Frankreich. Und Piketty schreibt, das Abkommen zwischen den französischen linken Parteien im Rahmen der Neuen Volksunion ist eine hervorragende Nachricht für die französische und die europäische Demokratie. Wer darin bloß einen Triumph der Radikalität und des Extremismus sieht, hat offenkundig nichts von den Entwicklungen des Kapitalismus sowie den sozialen und ökologischen Herausforderungen verstanden, denen wir gegenüberstehen. Einer, der von sich reklamiert, er hat es verstanden mit dem Kapitalismus, ist natürlich Thomas Piketty. Und wir müssen sagen, ja, also warum sollte man ihm da jetzt nicht folgen? Dieses Programm, was da jetzt vorgelegt wird, ist eine gute Ausgangsbasis, um weiterzugehen, bis hin zu diesem Erbe für alle, das er ja schon häufiger vorgeschlagen hat. Es geht um soziale Gerechtigkeit und Steuergerechtigkeit, die dann auf die Agenda rücken. Und man muss sich die ökonomischen Grundlagen anschauen. Es ist unerlässlich, sich den Wohlstand gerade in Frankreich anzuschauen. Zwischen 2010 und 2022 sind die 500 größten französischen Vermögen von 200 Milliarden auf eine Billion Euro angewachsen, haben sich also verfünffacht. Das war eigentlich ein Krisen-Jahrzehnt, von Lehman Brothers bis Griechenland und so weiter. Das ist ja genau die Zeit. Das heißt, von 10 Prozent des BIP ist das auf 50 Prozent des BIPs hochgegangen. Also wenn man die Vergleiche zwischen Wirtschaftskraft und wie sind die Vermögen verteilt? Die 500.000 größten Vermögen sind auf 3 Billionen Euro gewachsen, was bedeutet, dass pro Person dort 6 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung stehen. Also bei den top 500.000 eines 60 Millionen Volkes, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz höre. 50 Prozent der Erwachsenenbevölkerung haben im Schnitt 20.000 Euro Vermögen. Und das ist dann 50 Prozent die untere Hälfte, also 50 Prozent, 30 Millionen zu 500.000 im Vergleich oder eben den reichsten 500 Vermögenden. Also wir sehen hier, es ist eine krasse Explosion der Ungleichheit und das Verdienst der linken Parteien ist nun ihre inneren Konflikte zu überwinden und sich wieder in diesen Dienst, kann man auch nicht sagen, aber in diese sich dieser Frage wieder zu widmen. Wie gehen wir jetzt eigentlich mit Vermögensteuer und Grundsteuer und Steuer auf Nettovermögen und so weiter um?
Mit Mélenchon dann an der Spitze?
Mit Mélenchon, das ist das Personalangebot. Wenn man es schafft, die Mehrheit zu erringen, wird Mélenchon als Premierminister gewählt. Man hätte dann, es gibt da einen Begriff für das erste Mal seit langem wieder den französischen Präsidenten unter Druck gesetzt, dass er eben nicht von seiner eigenen Partei im Parlament einfach auf Mehrheiten hoffen kann. Und naja, Piketty baut das dann aus zu so einer Hinwendung. Wir könnten es ja irgendwie hinbekommen, eine soziale und steuerliche Harmonisierung in Europa und den Übergang zur Mehrheitsentscheidung in den europäischen Gremien– also er macht sozusagen diesen Brückenschlag von Frankreich nach Europa– mal hinzubekommen. Das wäre natürlich superschön. Wir hätten da vor allem mal wieder ein Vorbild, ein linkes Vorbild für Europa, auch für uns hier in Deutschland, dass wir da so ein bisschen vorwärts kommen. So könnte Frankreich, wie das European Tax Observatory gezeigt hat, ab sofort einen Mindeststeuersatz von 25 oder 30 Prozent auf diejenigen Unternehmen erheben, die in Steueroasen angesiedelt sind und in Frankreich Güter und Dienstleistungen verkaufen. Denkt man jetzt, was ist denn das für ein Argument? Das ist ja nur so eine Marginalien. Nein, das ist so Finale des Textes. Denn man hat sich jetzt auf 15 Prozent Mindeststeuersatz geeinigt und jetzt sagt er hier, nee, komm, lass uns doch 25, 30 Prozent machen. Wir bräuchten dafür nur ein europäisches Abstimmungsverfahren, das nicht einem einzigen Land ein Veto-Recht zugesteht. Und das wäre ja mit Mehrheit statt Einigkeit da gegeben. Das sehen wir ja gerade auch beim Ukraine-Krieg, dass wir das sechste Sanktionspaket nicht gegen den Widerstand Ungarns machen konnten, sondern da wieder ewig Gezuständnisse möglich und nötig waren. Hier einfach mal umstellen auf Mehrheitsentscheid, was ja dann hieße, die Hälfte der Länder und 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung, die repräsentiert werden müssen oder so. Also da könnte man schon relativ viel machen, unter anderem auch gegen Deutschland. Also das sind ja auch immer so Punkte, die man da zu beachten hat. Na ja, Pikette, die hat sich zu Wort gemeldet und das ist natürlich richtig und wichtig und zeigt uns nochmal, ah ja, in Frankreich steht jetzt eine wichtige Wahl an. Übersieht man ja leicht in diesen Nachbarländern.
In der Tat. Zum Schluss noch ein Buch von Amanda D. Lotz. Sie ist Medienwissenschaftlerin und sie hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Netflix and Streaming Video, The Business of Subscriber-funded Video on Demand und lasst mich mit einer Frage beginnen, Stefan, was haben, sagen wir, der König der Löwen, Pretty Woman und ziemlich beste Freunde gemeinsam?
Ähm, äh, es sind Filme, ja, aber vielmehr fällt dir wahrscheinlich dann nicht ein.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist schon eine gute Richtung. Sehr gut. Du denkst schon Netflix-mäßig, das ist, das war jetzt genau die richtige Antwort. Man könnte auch sagen, sie sind herzerwärmend, vielleicht.
Ja, das stimmt, herzerwärmend.
Und zwar vereint diese Filme ja erst einmal nichts. Sie kommen zum Teil aus unterschiedlichen Ländern, wir haben Zeichentrick-Filme, das eine ist eine Komödie, das andere ist ein Liebesfilm, das andere ist so ein Abenteuer-Zeichentrick-Ding. Aber man könnte sagen, die sind irgendwie dann positiv in ihrem Ausgang, sie sind herzerwärmend in dem, was sie erzählen. Und nehmen wir mal an, Netflix wüsste jetzt, dass du solche Filme magst, also die haben jetzt alle drei Filme, du hast die alle drei bei Netflix geguckt, dann sagen die herzerwärmend, das ist also ein Ton, den der Film haben muss oder eine Serie haben muss, damit Stefan die gut findet. Und dann bekommst du aufgrund dieser Kategorie herzerwärmt vielleicht die nächste Serie vorgestellt, die möglicherweise in Indien spielt und von Großeltern handelt. Aber die also auch ganz anders wieder ist, aber doch vielleicht das herzerwärmende ist, dass sie das wieder gefällt. Das ist eine Kategorisierung, die man früher nicht vorgenommen hat. Früher hätte man geguckt nach Alter, ist es ein Familienfilm, FSK, sowas hätte man betrachtet. Man hätte auf Länder geblickt, wo es das produziert, aber plötzlich gibt es diese andere Komponente. Und das ist nur ein Beispiel, um zu sagen, wie anders diese Streaming-Plattformen funktionieren und wie anders vor allem Netflix funktioniert. Und ich glaube, man hat sich das noch gar nicht so klar vor Augen geführt, was das eigentlich heißt im Vergleich zum Kino. Im Kino ist es ja so, dass man im Unterhaltungskino jeden Donnerstag neue Filme hat. Aber eigentlich sind da ein, zwei, drei Filme, die aus Hollywood kommen. Das ist dann mal Top Gun. Das ist jetzt diese Woche Jurassic Park. Und das ist nächste Woche, glaube ich, ein Film mit Nicolas Cage. So diese Filme müssen ein möglichst großes Publikum erreichen. Und zwar möglichst global. Wie schafft man das? Man schafft das zum Beispiel durch Superstars, die jeder kennt, durch Erzählungen, die schon etabliert sind, wie bei Top Gun oder Jurassic Park. Und man schafft das natürlich durch eine möglichst große Zielgruppe. Und das geht dann über den Familienfilm. Dass man sagen kann, okay, da kann Stefan mit den Kindern eingehen. Da geht aber auch der Familienvater in Indien vielleicht sogar rein, weil das eine Geschichte ist mit süßen Tieren und alle Menschen finden Tiere süß oder sowas. Netflix funktioniert vollkommen anders. Netflix hat zwar auch irgendwelche Hits wie Squid Game oder so, aber Amanda D. Lotz sagt, das ist gar nicht so wichtig. Das macht in gewisser Weise mal Werbung für die Plattform. Alle reden über Squid Game oder über Tiger King. Aber was ist eigentlich das Wichtige für eine Streaming-Plattform? Dass die Abonnenten bleiben und neue Abonnenten hinzukommen. Und die Abonnenten haben ganz unterschiedliche Bedürfnisse, die diese Plattformen stillen sollen. Da gibt es denen, der das Bedürfnis hat, herzerwärmende Filme zu sehen. Oder da gibt es identitätspolitisch jetzt gesehen, jemand möchte gerne Geschichten von jungen lesbischen Frauen sehen. Nun kann man immer sagen, also Filmkunst muss natürlich alle irgendwie ansprechen. Und jetzt als Filmkritiker interessiert man sich so fast für alle Filme, würde ich mal sagen. Und da sind andere Fragen wichtig. Aber sehr viele Leute gucken ja Filme in irgendeiner Weise identifikatorisch. Und das Problem ist jetzt, dass natürlich alle, die jetzt nicht vom Familienfilm sich nur identifiziert fühlen, bzw. das ist ja nur schon dieses Zugeständnis. Aber wir machen irgendwie so einen Familienfilm, da hat jeder ein bisschen was von. Aber sobald die Interessen ein bisschen spezieller werden, wird es sehr schwierig, das im Kino noch zu bringen. Weil man muss dieses, diesen, man hat ja nur einen Kinosaal oder man hat vielleicht fünf Kinosaale, aber man muss an diesem Wochenende erfolgreich sein, sonst fliegt man auch wieder raus. Bei Netflix ist das zum Beispiel vollkommen anders. Es reicht, wenn sagen wir, die Serie über Probleme von Transpersonen, also die sich auch ganz dezidiert vor allem an Transpersonen richtet. Also gar nicht eine Serie, die irgendwie universalisierbar ist. Wie zum Beispiel einen Film wie Lawrence Anyways, der handelt zwar von einer Transperson, aber das ist jetzt nichts, was sagen kann, es nicht irgendwie verhandelt Probleme von Transpersonen. Aber wenn es jetzt wirklich eine Serie von und für Transpersonen ist, dann kann das bei Netflix 100.000 Leute erreichen, und zwar global. Und diese sind aber aufgrund dessen gewillt, ihr Abo zu behalten. Dann ist das für Netflix genauso erfolgreich wie die 100.000 Leute, die dazukommen, weil Squid Game gerade läuft. Das heißt, wir haben bei den Videodiensten es mit Parallelität zu tun, im Gegensatz zu Linearität, die das Fernsehen oder das Kino uns anbietet. In einem Kino kann um 20 Uhr immer nur das eine stattfinden. Amanda Dilots sagt, eigentlich ist es Netflix egal, ob eine Million Menschen gerade Squid Game gucken bei Netflix oder ob die ein Millionen Menschen alles Mögliche gerade bei Netflix gucken. Wichtig ist, dass die bei Netflix das gucken. Und deswegen ist diese Diversität, die durch diese Plattform entsteht, enorm groß. Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir jetzt da eine neue Filmkunst unbedingt erleben, sondern das, was ich eben dich ja gefragt habe nach den Gemeinsamkeiten, also nach des Tons des Films oder auch mit Geschmacksklustern wird da gearbeitet. Das ist natürlich Algorithmen getrieben. Darauf geht im Endeffekt die Lotz auch ein. Aber erst einmal die große Überlegung ist, wir haben es nun mit einer Bibliothek zu tun bei Netflix. Und wir haben es nicht mit linearem Programm zu tun. Und Bibliothek meint, dass dort ganz viel parallel stattfinden kann, ohne dass das eine das andere verdrängt, wodurch ganz andere Programmentscheidungen getroffen werden können, als in irgendwelchen linear ausgerichteten Formaten. Sie sagt, es ist im linear ausgerichteten Format so, jeder müsste ein Buch lesen und nur das. Eine Bibliothek funktioniert aber genauso nicht. Sondern jeder kann sich das Buch suchen, das er gerne haben möchte.
Aber leidet Netflix nicht auch darunter ein bisschen? Ich sehe immer jetzt, dass Amazon ja doch so auch ins Live-Programm geht, gerade beim Sport. Fußballspiele, die bei Amazon übertragen werden. Wenn ich bei Netflix durchscrolle, sehe ich ja irgendwann in der dritten oder vierten Regalebene, ist heute auch gerade in Deutschland auf Platz 1, 2, 3 und 4. Wo sie mir ja vorgaukeln, da guckst du nicht alleine. Da sind auch andere, die sich dafür interessieren. Und dieses Gefühl scheint für dieses, ich schaue irgendwas, doch irgendwie wichtig zu sein. Leuten ist ja wichtig, Top Gun ist im Kino, oh, dann gehe ich mal gleich am ersten Wochenende. Weil ich will ja nicht nur den Film sehen, sondern auch im Diskurs stehen und so. Und dieses Gefühl schafft Netflix so gar nicht. Also klar, Bibliothek, Archiv und so weiter, Katalog, aber ich glaube Amazon, die treffen da gerade bessere Entscheidungen.
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Also das mag sein, dass es ja auch immer noch diesen Wunsch nach Gemeinsamkeit gibt. Man guckt irgendwas zusammen, das kann auch ein Kanzler-Duell sein oder ein Fußballspiel.
Aber diese Ten, da hast du vollkommen recht, die ist idiotisch. Das sagt sie auch. Also diese sagt gar nichts aus. Die sagt ja nur, dass zu einer, in einem bestimmten Zeitraum ganz viele Leute diesen Film oder diese Serie mindestens zwei Minuten lang gesehen haben. Und zwar die ersten zwei Minuten, da wird das gezählt. Und das ist einfach nur so eine Nonsenskategorie, die eigentlich davon ablenkt, wie Netflix eigentlich funktioniert. Aber was die Leute eigentlich interessiert, ist, dass sie friktionslos einen Zugang zu Inhalten bekommen, die die Gefühle bestätigen oder das das das Erwünschte zeigen. Und da ja jede Seite eines jeden Nutzers anders aussieht, also wenn ich Netflix öffne, wird mir anderes angezeigt als dir. Das zeigt sich da auch schon sehr gut, inwieweit eigentlich diese Netflix-Oberfläche und auch viele andere Streaming-Oberflächen ein bisschen so funktionieren wie die 4U-Seite bei TikTok, die algoritmusgetrieben ist und dann die Vorauswahl trifft. In Top 10 zu denken, ist vollkommen antiquiert, sagt Amanda Dilots. Man muss nur gucken, Abos im Monat, das ist das Entscheidende und hinzukommt auch, dass Netflix überlegt, welche Befriedigungen also Leute aus dem Content ziehen. Und sie sehen dann, zwar mag es da Leute geben, also wahrscheinlich gibt es natürlich mehr Leute, die Squid Game geguckt haben als eine LGBT-Serie. Aber Netflix rankt das schon unterschiedlich und guckt also, wo ist eigentlich der spezifische Content, der von den Abonnenten am meisten gewürdigt wurde. Und das ist dann nicht Squid Game, das die Bindung zu Netflix aufgebaut hat, sondern das ist diese eine Serie, die dieser User sich ansieht und hier vielleicht sogar ein zweites Mal guckt oder wo er nie irgendetwas vorspult. Und da wissen die, okay, diese Serie ist eigentlich Gold wert, denn die hält ihn im Abo und es ist nicht Squid Game, die hat er sich auch angeguckt, weil, wie du jetzt gerade sagst, alle mal über Squid Game gingen. Aber eigentlich geht es mehr um dieses ganz individualisierte Schauen. Und daraus ergibt sich auch zum Beispiel eine andere Produktionslogik bei den Serien. Wir wissen im Fernsehen, wenn eine Serie erfolgreich ist, gibt es eine Fortsetzung. Und das kann dann dazu führen, dass man 30 Jahre Lindenstraße hat oder reich und schön und wie das alles heißt. Das ist für Netflix uninteressant, weil die wissen, wir können zwar so jemanden irgendwie bei der Stange halten, aber erstmal akquirieren wir keine neuen Abonnenten mehr damit. Und es ist mehr dann so, das Fernsehen ist einfach froh, Gott sei Dank, wir haben so einen Konsens gefunden. Jetzt lasst uns einfach das Pferd zu Tode reiten. Netflix macht deswegen häufig Serien mit ein, zwei oder maximal drei Folgen. Mehr gibt es nicht. Das andere interessiert Netflix nicht, von wenigen Ausnahmen, wo man nicht umhin kommt, mal abgesehen. Ist das für Netflix und auch für andere Streaming-Dienste nicht interessant? Demografie ist keine Frage für die Streaming-Dienste, denn es geht um diese Geschmackskluster. Und das kann sein, dass ein 70-Jähriger gerne Zeichentrick-Filme sieht und dann fällt er in dieses Cluster und das interessiert nicht. Dann mehr das Alter. Taste-Clusters sind das Entscheidende für Netflix. Und es ergeben sich ja, wenn man das mal so ganz durchdenkt, unglaublich viele Überlegungen dazu. Netflix-Produktionen, also jede Netflix-Bibliothek unterscheidet sich länderspezifisch. Das hat mit den Lizenzen natürlich zu tun. Die Mehrzahl der zum Beispiel in den USA erhältlichen Filme auf Netflix stammt nicht aus den USA. Und in keinem Land gibt es mehr als 50% oder mehr als 45% US-amerikanische Filme. Das heißt, wir haben hier auch eine geographische Verschiebung, die stattfindet, die enorm ist, die wir im Kino nie erleben. Im Kino sehen wir mal diesen einen südkoreanischen Film, der dann bei den Oscars geworden hat oder so. Aber in der Regel ist das US-amerikanisch beziehungsweise vom Nationalmarkt tendiert. Bei uns sind es dann Til Schweiger-Komödien. Bei Netflix ist das vollkommen anders. Es gibt deutsche Serien wie Dark, ist im Ausland erfolgreicher als in Deutschland. Also, ich glaube, in Argentinien wurde mehr geguckt als in Deutschland. Und dadurch verschiebt sich natürlich so enorm viel. Also, auch diese ganzen Debatten um Repräsentation werden allein durch diese andere technische Möglichkeit plötzlich, ja, man möchte fast sagen, obsolete. Und die Autorin geht dann auch durch, sie hat dann selbst geguckt, welche Serien guckt sie eigentlich, was guckt sie. Und dann ist sie auch immer auf solche Taste-Clusters gestoßen. Und Nähe ist ganz wichtig, also, dass eine Nähe zu den Streaming-Diensten entsteht beim Abonnenten. Aber diese Nähe ist nicht mehr geknüpft an Lokalität, was wir ja erst mal sagen würden. Aber wenn wir uns schon mal, und eigentlich kommt das auch uns viel näher, denn du bist zwar Deutscher, aber hast du eine Nähe zum deutschen Film? Wahrscheinlich nicht, du hast die Nähe zu irgendeinem amerikanischen Action-Film. Genau, Michael Bay. Da hast du eine viel größere Nähe zu, als wenn jetzt in Frankfurt ein Film entstehen würde.
Ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt, wie fern mir immer Premiere war. Premiere war immer der Sender, den irgendwelche Leute irgendwo für irgendwas und so, dann so amal einen Premiere-Film geguckt, weil er irgendwie was sich angeboten hat. Es wäre völlig undenkbar, dass ich mich selber in so einer Publikumsklasse, ich zahle jetzt fürs Fernsehen, bei Netflix und so, spielt das gar keine Rolle. Also die 17 Euro, die es ja inzwischen kostet, damit auch viele Kinder gleichzeitig was gucken können, werden einfach so bezahlt.
Ja, wenn wir im Kino momentan so sind, im Unterhaltungskino, dann sehen wir diese Familienfilme. Und ich würde auch so eine gewisse Infantilisierung da beobachten, dass man, egal aus welchem Film am Ende noch einen Familienfilm macht, das sieht man auch daran, dass Sex oder so nicht mehr vorkommt, sondern man macht eigentlich immer Filme, die man auch mit 9-Jährigen sehen kann. Bei Netflix ist das anders. Das Familienprogramm macht 14 Prozent aus. Es gibt sehr viel erwachsenen Content, um es mal sozusagen, also Geschichten von Erwachsenen für Erwachsener. Die haben Disney Plus, das funktioniert um was anderes. Darauf geht Lots auch ein. Aber man kann sehen, dass also durch diese neue technische Möglichkeit, durch dieses Verfahren auch Geld zu verdienen, nur über Abonnenten, nicht über Werbung, nicht über diese Zielgruppen gehen, dass das eine neue Art von Filmen und Serien hervorbringt, dass sich also allein durch Technik und Geschäftsmodell die Erzählweise ändert. Dass wir jetzt schon eine andere Form von Filmen und Serien erleben und eine große geographische Verschiebung weg von Hollywood. Hollywood ist noch nicht marginalisiert, Hollywood ist immer noch sehr dominant und vieles wird natürlich auch von Hollywood übernommen. Aber wir erleben eigentlich hier eine neue Art des Filmemachens und auch des Filme-Rezipierens. Und man darf gespannt sein, wohin sich das entwickelt. Ich finde jedenfalls, dass Menderlotz diese einzelnen Punkte sehr gut einmal durchgeht. Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn wir sagen, ja, Streaming-Dienste sind jetzt da? Und dass man von so einer ganz simplen Überlegung dann ausgeht und mal auffächert, was das eigentlich bedeutet und wie sich das verändert. Das relativiert auch sehr viele Debatten, die so gerade geführt werden, wie Divers muss Hollywood werden und all das. Es bewegt sich vielleicht auch gerade von Hollywood weg, dann ist Hollywood ohnehin nicht mehr so wichtig. Gerade sehr erfolgreich in dutzenden Ländern, mehr und mehr jetzt auch in Deutschland, ist ein Film, der heißt RRR., der dauert zweieinhalb Stunden und stammt aus Indien und hat wirklich mit dem klassischen Hollywood-Kino sehr, sehr wenig zu tun.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie es mit Netflix weitergeht. Der Börsenkurs ist unter Druck, weshalb die da auch diese Einstellungsstops und so weiter und sogar Feuer... Also sehr viele Leute müssen da jetzt auch wirklich gehen. Auf der anderen Seite, das mit den 14 Prozent wahrscheinlich ist es so eine qualitative Sache. Wenn unsere Kinder Netflix aufrufen und dann in ihr Kinderprofil gehen, sehen sie doch schon in der ersten Zeile drei, vier verschiedene Sachen, die in echter Konkurrenz zueinander stehen, was sie gucken wollen. Während, wenn ich Netflix aufmache, ich schon eine Weile scrollen muss, bis ich dann mal irgendwas anklicke. Also ich bin gerade so ein bisschen raus aus diesem Guck. Mal sehen, ob sie mich dann irgendwann wieder eingefangen kriegen. Als Kinderprogramm läuft es gerade besser als Disney+. Mal gucken, ob sie das irgendwie ausbauen. So, damit haben wir alles verhandelt und besprochen, was uns untergekommen ist. Wer weiß, was es noch so alles gab in dieser weiten Welt. Wir hören uns dann Ende des Monats wieder, Juni, das Gut. Das ist für mich der erste Monat, in dem ich frei vom Buchschreiben und so weiter bin, um hier ordentlich Podcasts zu produzieren.
Wunderbar.
Ich bin gespannt, was sich finden lässt an Themen.
Ein schönen Monat.
Yes, haut rein. Bis dann.